bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition de
24h Sénat pour une après-midi consacré
aux travaux parlementaires de la Haute
Assemblée et au sommaire de ce 24h Sénat
la séance consacrée à l'examen du projet
de loi de financement de la Sécurité
social ce sera aux alentours de 16h35 à
19h le journal suivi du débat consacré
ce soir à la hausse de la TVA avec les
sénateurs François Marc pour le Parti
socialiste et Francis de lâre pour l'UMP
mais avant cela deux informations de la
matinée au Sénat la commission des
finances du Sénat adopté ce matin lors
de l'examen du projet de loi de finances
un amendement qui veut inclure les clubs
de football français qui ont un statut
particulier comme par exemple l'as
Monaco dans la taxation à 75 %. et autre
information cette fois venant des
sénateurs communistes ils ont confirmé
ce matin lors d'une conférence de presse
leur intention de voter contre le budget
de la Sécurité sociale ils jugent son
financement insuffisant et s'inquiète de
la situation des hôpitaux comme nous
l'explique Laurence Cohen au micro de
Camila
campousano pour moi le gouvernement une
politique de court terme qui ne prend
pas du tout en compte la situation déjà
catastrophique des hôpitaux il aurait
fallu et il faudrait et c'est possible
de le faire une politique qui tourne le
dos au choix précédent et qui donc
permettre de donner une bouffée
d'oxygène un nouvel espoir au personnel
il faut des embauches il faut des
qualifications il faut des formation il
faut tout ça à
l'hôpital le volet recette devrait donc
être rejeté le volet recette du projet
de loi de financement de la Sécurité
social par le Sénat tout comme l'article
12 TER sur les mutuels qui a été
supprimé cet après-midi c'était l'une
des mesures très discutées de ce texte
alors de quoi s'agissait-il on va tout
de suite retrouver Tam tranui en duplexe
de l'hémicycle bonsoir Tam oui bonjour
Delphine sur ces mutuel et bien oui
cette mesure était à l'origine de tout
un mouvement de contestation des
salariés des petites mutuelles les
fameux bonnets jaunes alors que
contestait-il et bien il contestait
l'article 12 terre qui vise à
contraindre toutes les entreprises d'une
même branche d'activité à prendre la
même mutuelle sous peine de devoir payer
une taxe supplémentaire cette mesure
pour le gouvernement permet d'étendre la
couverture santé des salariés des PME
salariés qui sont souvent mal protégés
beaucoup n'ont pas de mutuel mais pour
les bonnets jaunes pour les salariés des
petites mutuelles et bien cela favoriser
et bien les grands instituts des
prévoyances au détriment des petites
mutuelles et donc cela revient à
remettre en danger tout de même 30 à
40000 emplois et les sénateurs ont donc
entendu et bien ce mouvement de
contestation puisquils ont supprimé cet
article oui tout à fait 217 sénateurs
sur 343 ont choisi de voter l'amendement
de suppression donc il y avait l'UMP les
centristes le groupe RDSE ce groupe à
majorité de radicaux de gauches les
écologistes mais aussi les communistes
ça le reste donc les socialistes qui ont
voté pour après une discussion très
compliquée chahuté tendu le rapporteur
général il dodini rapporteur général de
la commission des Affaires soci a eu du
mal à s'exprimer tout comme la ministre
Marie saltouren qui a été prise à parti
par l'opposition à noté cette mesure et
bien ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'elle passe à l'AS puisqu'elle était
déjà présente dans une loi de janvier
2013 loi transposant l'accord sur
l'emploi elle était présente s une forme
un peu différente mais çavenait
quasiment au même puis elle cette mesure
avait été retoquée au mois de juin par
le Conseil constitutionnel qu'il avait
jugé contraire à la liberté
d'entreprendre et à la liberté
contractuelle
merci beaucoup Tam pour ces explications
alors sans plus tarder bien direction
l'hémicycle pour revoir l'intégralité de
ces débat autour de l'article 12 TER et
on se retrouve à 19h pour le
journal l'ordre du jour appelle la suite
de la discussion du projet de loi adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour
2014 nous allons examiner les
dispositions de la 3ème partie relative
aux recettes et à l'équilibre financier
de la sécurité sociale
pour l'exercice
2014 nous passons à l'article 12 TER qui
est appelé en priorité à la demande de
la commission des affaires sociales sur
cet article dou j'ai plusieurs demande
de parole dont celle de Monsieur
Jean-Noël Cartou qui a la parole
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
le Ministre chers collègues euh nous
vous revoilà revenu sur cette clause de
désignation dont nous avions beaucoup
parlé au printemps et cet article je le
qualifierai de démarche à la tartuf par
laquelle se couvert de respecter la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
prononcé au moment du vote de la loi
relative à la sécuration sécurisation de
l'emploi et posant le principe de la
libre concurrence le gouvernement met en
place une clause de recommandation par
branche pour les adhésions obligatoires
au complémentaire santé en faisant
rentrer dans le droit chemin les
entrepreneurs qui ne la respecteraient
pas en surtaxant à 8 % les entreprises
de moins de 10 salariés et à 14 celles
de plus de 10 quelle
hypocrisie cet article soulève de
nombreuses critiques d'abord sur la
forme on se demande ce qu'un tel article
vient faire dans le volet recette d'un
PLFSS alors que comme le gouvernement
l'a lui-même reconnu cette surtaxation
se veut incitative et n'a pas comme
objectif l'équilibre des comptes de la
Sécurité sociale il il ne concerne pas
le régime de base de la sécurité sociale
mais des régimes
complémentaires il s'agit donc ni plus
ni moins que d'un cavaliier introduit
par le gouvernement sur la pression de
certaines organisations syndicales et
nous avons eu l'occasion ce matin en
commission de rejeter des amendements
qui étaient présentés mais rejetés sur
le même fondement de recettes annexes
sur le fond
ensuite il s'agit d'une rupture
d'égalité des contribuables devant
l'impôt atteinte à la liberté
d'entreprendre et surtout une
dénaturation de la liberté contractuelle
donc manifestement malgré l'apparence
d'ouverture à la concurrence cet article
je pense doit s'il est adopté subir à
nouveau la censure du Conseil
constitutionnel j'ajoute qu'aucune
motivation d'intérêt général n'y préside
au contraire des arguments avancés par
le gouvernement limiter la mutualisation
à des accords de branche diminue son
efficacité comptenue de l'échantillon
plus faible des personnes concerné il y
a donc aucune justification technique il
faut au contraire prendre en compte les
mutualisation
intergénérationnelle
interprofessionnelle et géographique qui
sont les bases de fonctionnement de tout
assureur santé et laisser la libre
concurrence s'instaurer c'est cet acte
de solidarité en dehors des accords de
branche que les professionnels de
l'assurance doivent mettre en œuvre ce
qu'ils savent parfaitement faire en fait
souscouvert de générer une meilleure
mutualisation c'est un retour larvé au
régime des corporations et en réalité
cette recommandation forcée aura comme
résultat de faire financer indirectement
les grandes entreprises par les petites
lesquelles petites entreprises bien
naturellement avec un nombre réduit de
salariés
sont beaucoup moins consommatrices de
soins que peuvent l'être les salariés
des grandes entreprises le résultat est
connu d'avance si cet article est adopté
90 % des contrats seront attribués aux
instituts de prévoyance au détriment des
assureurs et des mutuels et les
conséquences immédiates ce sera de
priver immédiatement d'emploi des
milliers de personnes nous avons vu
depuis hier la prestation des salariés
inquiets devant les portes du Sénat
et on comprend mieux dans ces condition
pourquoi ce qui justifie en fait la
démarche de retour
devant la représentation national d'un
d'un tel article d'une telle clause de
recommandation et bien c'est le lobbying
des syndicats tant salariés que
patronaux qui sont paritaire dans les
institutions de prévoyance et qui
veulent continuer autour de la table à
se partager une man financière c'est une
étatisation larvé de la politique de
santé à travers les mutuels donc voilà
pourquoi à plusieurs titres à la fois
sur la justification sur la démarche
constitutionnelle sur le fond et bien
cet article est indéfendable
et voilà pourquoi le groupe UMP va vous
présenter dans quelques minutes un
amendement de
suppression merci chers collègues madame
mugdini a maintenant la parole pour le
groupe UD
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous allons
donc reprendre nos débats sur clause de
recommandation et clause de
désignation sur ce sujet notre groupe
udiuc a toujours défendu le tri strict
respect du texte de la ni du 11 janvier
2013 cela étant nous devons reconnaître
que dans certains cas la clause de
désignation s'impose par essence en
effet la négociation collective et la
gestion d'un régime de prévoyance de
branche a pu emprunter des formes très
diverses les partenaires sociaux
pouvaient soit sélectionner un contrat
assuré par un ou plusieurs organismes
assureurs déterminés soit décider de la
création par la voie conventionnel d'un
organisme assureur déterminé dont
l'objet exclusif était de couvrir les
salariés et anciens salariés de la
branche les partenaires sociaux ont eu
recours à cette seconde possibilité
lorsque les
particularités d'une branche
professionnelle les ont conduit à
développer une politique sociale
particulièrement affirmée en raison
essentiellement des conditions de
travail difficiles ou spécifiques ce
type d'organisme dédié à une branche
professionnelle et qui n'intervient pas
sur d'autres marchés doit pouvoir
continuer à exister et je prendrai deux
exemples pour illustrer mon propos le
secteur du bâtiment et des travaux
publics le secteur des particulier
employeur le secteur d'activité du BTP a
depuis l'immédiate après guerre
développé une tradition de relation
paritaire forte cette tradition a permis
la conclusion par l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux de plusieurs accords
de branche qui notamment de 1947 à
1968 ont créé un régime de
complémentaire retraite santé et
prévoyance particulièrement performant
ainsi que les organismes chargés de lesg
il s'agit depuis
1993 du groupe paritaire professionnel
que tout le monde connaît de protection
sociale à bu non lucratif PRO BTP en
l'état actuel du droit toutes les
entreprises du secteur de BTP sont tenu
d' d'adhérer à ProBTP qui offre à leurs
salariés les garanties prévues par les
accords de branche étendus par arrêté
ministériel l'idée qui a prévalu à la
création de ce dispositif était triple
il s'agissait premièrement de mutualiser
des risques qui individuellement pour
certaines entreprises du secteur
notamment les plus petites auraient été
trop lourd à porter ou à faire assuré
deuxièmement de développer une politique
d'action sociale forte troisièmement
d'éviter les coûts de transaction
impliqués par le recours à une entité
extérieure à la branche ainsi voulu par
toute la profession cette institution de
prévoyance professionnelle permet la
mise en place d'une véritable solidarité
professionnel entre tous les salariés et
une mutualisation du risque pour tout le
secteur du
BTP la suppression du droit pour les
partenaires sociaux de disposer dans une
branche d'un organisme assureur dédié
auquel les entreprises sont tenus
d'adhérer pour la prévoyance dans le BTP
remet en cause la solidarité
professionnelle de ce secteur ce seront
les petites entreprises qui seront
perdantes les plus grosses ayant la
capacité financière de négocier des
contrats à forte garantie auprès
d'autres organismes en ce qui concerne
les les branches professionnelles des
salariés du particulier employeur et des
assistants maternels du particulier
employeur on retrouve cette même
démarche de solidarité et de
mutualisation du risque les partenaires
sociaux ont créé l'IRSEM en
1973 groupe de protection sociale dédié
au salariés à domicile l'IRSEM assure et
gère la retraite complémentaire et les
régimes de prévoyance collective
négociés par les partenaires sociaux le
dispositif repose sur un appel indirect
des cotisations via l'URSAF ce qui
permet la mutualisation en effet un
salarié à domicile ou une assistante
maternelle ont très souvent plusieurs
employeurs si ce système de désignation
de l'IRSEM est remis en cause les
particuliers employeurs seront dans
l'incapacité d'effectuer un choix
individuel en matière de couverture de
prévoyance et les sal salariés de ce
secteur risque de ne plus être couvert
en cas d'incapacité et d'invalidité au
passage je me demande comment le césu va
gérer les différentes mutuelles des
particuliers employeurs je présenterai
un amendement numéro 80 qui vise à
reconnaître la spécificité de ces deux
secteurs professionnels mais il en
existe d'autres en particulier celui du
du transport il est essentiel de
préserver ces entités qui sont nées
d'accord de branche professionnel et qui
incarne le régime de prévoyance des
salariés de ces branches madame la
ministre la balle est dans votre camp
c'est à vous de trouver la solution pour
que ces spécificités demeurent je vous
remercie merci chers collègues Monsieur
Jean
deésard sur cet
article président madame la ministre
collègues sénatrices et
sénateurs nous avons déposé un
amendement de suppression qui sera
présenté par ma collègue aneline
archimau de l'article dou cet article
issu d'un amendement du Gouvernement
déposé à l'Assemblée nationale
réintroduit de fait les clauses de
désignation dont nous avions discuté
pendant la ni et avant cela je souhaite
dans cette intervention évoquer un
argument souvent évoqué pour justifier
cette disposition celui de la
mutualisation il a en effet été avancé
de multiples reprises y compris par le
gouvernement pendant l'anné que la
mutualisation des risques serait
meilleure à l'échelle de la branche ce
qui justifierait la clause de
désignation rappelons d'abord que le
simple fait de généraliser la
complémentaire santé pour les salariés
exclu de fait les autres en effet les
salariés ne souscriront désormais plus
de contrat individuell et les organismes
d'assurance seront donc contraints de ne
mutualiser leur portefeuille de contrat
individuel que sur le reste de la
population qui présente statistiquement
plus de risque ces personnes à savoir
les inactifs les chômeurs les étudiants
les retraités verront donc leur
cotisation
augmenté s'ils décide de souscrire une
complémentaire à titre individuel alors
même qu'ils n'ont par définition aucune
entreprise pour prendre en charge une
partie de leur
cotisation
maintenant intéressons-nous à l'effet
des accords de branche le besoin de
mutualisation en santé est très
particulier ne correspond pas au besoins
habituels connus en technique
d'assurance par exemple en matière de
prévoyance en voyance le décès le risque
décès ou d'invalidité lourd à couvrir
présente une faible fréquence
d'occurrence de l'ordre de à 3 cas pour
1000 personnes en santé ces mêmes 1000
personnes couvertes procureront plus de
15000 sinon 20000 événements de coup
modéré à garantir annuellement recours à
des médecins plusieurs fois dans l'année
dépenses de pharmacie auxiliaires
médicaux et cetera et cetera sans
oublier les gros risques comme
l'hospitalisation fort heureusement
nettement moins fréquent le le risque de
santé est donc un risque de court terme
à montant limité de forte fréquence il
en résulte qu'il est aisément
maîtrisable et ne nécessite que peu
d'assuré pour être garanti les actuaires
estiment que le seuil à partir duquel le
risque santé est mutualisé est de
l'ordre de la centaine d'assurés c'est
d'ailleurs également le raisonnement que
tient l'administration fiscale en effet
pour que leur risque soit réellement
garantis les organismes d'assurance sont
soumis à des règles prudentielles il
aurait imposé
la constitution de provision
d'égalisation c'est-à-dire des
provisions faites pour assurer le bon
paiement des engagements qui sont
fonction du nombre d'assurés le niveau
des provisions demandées est bien sûr
d'autant plus faible que les populations
assurées sont importantes c'est-à-dire
que la mutualisation est jugée la plus
solide par exemple la dernière tranche
reconnue par l'administration pour un
contrat prévoyance est fixée à 500000
personnes en santé en revanche aucun
seuil n'a été retenu la qualité de la
mutualisation en santé ne dépend donc
pas du nombre d'assurés mais de leur
profil les besoins de mutualisation en
santé ne sont en fait que de deux ordres
intergénérationnel de façon à assurer
une solidarité avec les personnes plus
jeunes et plus âgées interprofessionnel
afin que les risques ne portent pas sur
des populations homogènes et puissent
ainsi être réparti entre des groupes à
consommation de soins variables ces deux
mutualisation et notamment la seconde
sont en réalité bien mieux garantis par
une mutualisation transversale branche
que par une mutualisation de branches le
plus souvent homogène il existe en effet
un risque systémique à concentrer les
risques de branche un même organisme
assureur par exemple dans le cas où
surviendrai des pathologies de branche
comme celle de la miante bien sûr qu'il
s'agit de prévenir il faut ajouter à
cela que la mutualisation par branche
génère d'importantes inégalités selon
que les branches soi sont plus ou moins
riches cette segmentation des risques et
des revenus peut même être vu comme un
détournement de la mutualisation
d'autant plus que les branches à haut
revenu non sont ne sont généralement pas
celles qui ont les risques les plus
élevés les hauts revenus ne payeront
donc plus les risques plus importants
des plus pauvres il me SEM donc madame
la ministre mes chers collègues que
l'argument d'une meilleure mutualisation
est non seulement faux mais dangereux
socialement merci chers collègues nous
allons discuter maintenant en discussion
commune quatre
amendements le premier l'amendement
numéro 107 rectifié Monsieur Alain Milan
oui monsieur le Président merci vous
avez évidemment sous les yeux l'ensemble
de l'exposé des motif sur cet article 12
TER je voudrais juste redire que le
Conseil constitutionnel dans sa décision
du 13 juin dernier a jugé que les
clauses de désignation portent à la
liberté d'entreprendre et à la liberté
contractuelle une atteinte
disproportionné au regard de l'objectif
poursuivi de mutualisation des risques
notre collègue Jean-Noël Cardous a
expliqué pourquoi nous avons déposer cet
amendement de suppression et je voudrais
m'adresser à madame la ministre pour lui
dire que le 22 octobre madame la
ministre à l'Assemblée nationale vous
avez déposé l'amendement visant à
introduire ces clauses de recommandation
après l'article 45 dans la 4e partie du
PLFSS relative aux
dépenses le lendemain le 3 octobre vous
avez fait rectifier l'amendement pour
finalement l'insérer après l'article 12
dans la 3è partie de ce texte relatif
aux recettes vous avez ensuite justifié
sa sa recevabilité en loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale au seul prétexte
que l'un des paragraphes du dit
amendement prévoit un malus fiscal pour
les entreprises qui décideraient
d'exercer leur liberté de choix puis
vous aveze justifier cette
discrimination fiscale par votre volonté
et je vous cite d'inciter les
entreprises à adopter des contrat à
forte valeur de solidarité vous attendez
donc madame la ministre de cette mesure
que les entreprises suivent massivement
la recommandation des branches
professionnelles ma question est donc
très simple à combien chiffrez-vous le
rendement de cette mesure pour le budget
de la Sécurité
sociale merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant
à Monsieur roche pour l'amendement
numéro
146 collègue l'objet de cet amendement
qui est présenté par le groupe uduc est
de supprimer cet article qui entend
réinstaurer la clause de
désignation Madame dinny A a fait
l'argumentaire dans son propos tout à
l'heure pour mémoire cette dernière
avait été instauré à l'article 1er de la
loi de sécurisation de l'emploi en
contradiction totale avec la lettre même
de l'accord national interprofessionnel
du 11 janvier 2013 qu'elle était
pourtant censé transcrire
fidèlement une véritable bataille avait
été menée contre la clause de
désignation au Sénat reconfiguration
forcée et oligopolistique de l'offre
complémentaire conflit d'intérêt entre
partenaires sociaux juges et partis
méconnaissance du droit de la
concurrence pression de la hausse des
prix au détriment des assurés et des
entreprises augmentation des primes des
non salariés destruction d'emploi je ne
reviens pas sur toutes les raisons de
fond qui justifie ce combat lors de
l'examen du projet de loi de
sécurisation de l'emploi le Sénat avait
obtenu des garanties mais largement
insuffisantes puisque comme cela a été
prévisible le Conseil constitutionnel a
censuré la clause de désignation le 13
juin 2013 comportant atteinte à la
liberté d'entreprendre et la liberté
contractuelle sorti par la porte voilà
que la clause de désignation revient par
la petite fenêtre au sein de ce PLFSS
certes il ne s'agit plus de santé mais
de prévoyance certes il n'est plus
question expressément désignation mais
seulement de recommandation ce qui est
conforme à laani mais nous l'affirmons
il s'agit bien en réalité de recréer une
véritable clause de désignation pour au
moins deux raisons la première la
branche pourra ne recommander qu'un seul
opérateur et on se doute bien que la
plupart des entreprises surtout les
petites suivront systématiquement la
recommandation les petites entreprises
n'ont pas les moyens de mener une étude
de marché pour leur couverture
prévoyance elles ont autres choses à
faire deuxièmement la désignation est
d'autant plus certaine que sera
fiscalement sanctionné en cas de choix
d'un notre organisme le forfet social
sur les cotisations de prévoyance
passera de 8 à 20 % pour les entreprises
de plus de 10 salariés et de 0 à 8 %
pour les entreprises de moins de 10
salariés de même que l'article 1er de la
loi sécurisation de l'emploi aurait dû
être supprimé au Sénat et a été censuré
par le Conseil constitutionnel le
présent article doit aujourd'hui l'être
également merci chers collègues
l'amendement numéro
275 madame archambau
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues dans l'accord national
interprofessionnel à an tel qu'il avait
été établi par les partenaires sociaux
la possibilité leur été laissée au
niveau de chaque branche professionnelle
de négocier nationalement avec un
organisme d'assurance un contrat de
complémentaire santé qui serait ensuite
recommandé c'est-à-dire proposé mais pas
imposé aux entreprises de la branche
dans le texte du Gouvernement qui visait
à transposer cette a a ensuite été
ajouté une clause de désignation qui
permet au contraire d'imposer le contrat
négocié nationalement à toutes les
entreprises de la branche ainsi dans le
texte de transposition trois
possibilités étaient laissées à la
branche ne rien faire recommander ou
imposer et lors de l'examin de ce texte
le Sénat s'était prononcé contre cette
disposition qui avait ensuite été
réétablie par l'Assemblée nationale
avant d'être finalement cassé par le
Conseil constitutionnel dans son élan le
Conseil constitutionnel a même censuré
des dispositions antérieures à la ni il
était donc nécessaire que le législateur
s'empare à nouveau de cette question
pour autant la manière dont il est
procédé à ce nouvel examen nous laisse
quelques interrogations d'abord on ne
comprend pas très bien pourquoi cette
disposition a été introduite par
amendement plutôt que dans le texte
lui-même alors même que le sujet est
délicat il en résulte que nous ne
disposons pas d'études d'impact et qu'il
y a à nouveau de quoi s'interroger sur
la constitutionnalité de ce que vous
nous proposez en effet dans cette
nouvelle mouture la D ation a disparu et
seul subsiste la recommandation mais
cette recommandation est assortie d'une
augmentation de 12 points du forfait
social dès lors qu'on ne la respecte pas
ce qui équivaut de fait à en faire une
recommandation il y a tout de même nous
nous semble-t-il une certaine hypocrisie
à prétendre que les entreprises
conservent leur liberté de choix alors
qu'on donne un prix à cette liberté lors
de l'examen de la ennie nous étions
prononcés en défaveur des clauses de
désignation le dispositif que vous nous
proposez cette fois est à notre sens
encore pire puisque disparaît la
possibilité de simplement recommander
enfin sa dans sa rédaction l'article
indique que les garanties collectives
devront prévoir je cite un degré élevé
de solidarité si nous souscrivons
évidemment à cette volonté nous nous
interrogons tout de même sur le sens
juridique de cette formule pour toutes
ces raisons il nous semble que ce
dispositif imprécis et potentiellement
inconstitutionnel doit être travaillé
c'est pourquoi nous vous invitons à le
supprimer merci chers collègues
l'amendement
34 rectifieré monsieur Barbier oui
monsieur le Président Madame le Ministre
M chers collègues B cet amendement visa
également donc à supprimer cet article
je v pas reprendre tout le développement
qui a été fait mais je rappelle que la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel ne
faisait que conforter la décision qui
avait été prise par notre assemblée dans
cette cette ici au moment de la
discussion de l' ni sur ce dans cette
loi nous nous étions retrouvés
majoritaire pour supprimer cette clause
alors le gouvernement revient par en
biais détourné à la suite de la décision
du Conseil constitutionnel avec ce terme
de recommandation alors voit bien dans
cette affaire qu'on cherche à contourner
la décision du conseil et imposer euh
cette désignation puisque on instaure
une pénalité un forfait social qui a
plus que doubler on passe de 20 % au
lieu de 8 % on voit mal comment euh les
les branches
pourraient choisir en toute liberté ce
type de de de
désignation simplement je crois que pour
nous l'essentiel de cette
euh cette demande de suppression de cet
article ce sont les réserves vis-à-vis
de la liberté d'entreprendre de la
liberté contractuelle et de la libre
concurrence je crois que c'est ça qu'il
est important de supprimer et de laisser
bien entendu des possibilités à chance
égal de choisir un organisme assureur
pour chacune des des entreprises ou des
branches dans cette
affaire merci chers collègu je vais
demander l'avis de la commission sur ces
différents amendements monsieur
rapporteur
général merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
donc je vais donner l'avis de la
commission sur les quatre amendements de
de suppression de l'article douer le 107
rectifié qui a été présenté par Monsieur
Milon le 146 par Monsieur roche le 275
par Madame archembo et le 304 rectifié
par Monsieur Barbier alors quelques
éléments
d'appréciation depuis 50 ans la grande
majorité des branches professionnelles a
mise en place des accords de prévoyance
couvrant l'ensemble des entreprises et
des salariés du secteur concerné alors
de quoi s'agit-il exactement pour bien
comprendre il me semble important de
donner quelques exemples de prestation
ainsi servies au salariés un capital
décès pour la personne survivante une
rente d'éducation pour permettre aux
enfants de continuer leurs études en cas
de décès du salarié des anemnités
journalières ou des pensions venant
compléter celle de la sécurité sociale
en cas d'incapacité ou d'invalidité des
indemnités de fin de carrière une
assurance lors des déplacements
professionnels et cetera ce sont donc
des risques dit risques lourds qui
engagent l'assureur sur plusieurs années
ou sur des sommes importante à la suite
de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel les branches ne pourront
plus imposer aux entreprises d'adhérer à
de tels régimes de prévoyance je le
regrette mais c'est ainsi le
gouvernement tente de combler le vide
juridique j'aimerais bien savoir ce que
proposent de leur côté les auteurs des
amendements de suppression alors en
rester là et ne rien faire que va-t-il
arriver alors les conséquences seront
les plus fortes pour les salariés des
petites entreprises et pour ceux de
secteurs où les risques professionnels
sont les plus grands les petites
entreprises ne signeront pas de contrat
de prévoyance ou alors à niveau de
garantie très bas sinon les prix seront
beaucoup trop élevés pour elle c'est le
fondement même de l'assurance plus le
risque est réparti moins il coûte cher à
chacun quand un assureur proposera un
contrat de prévoyance en une entreprise
du BTP de 10 salariés quel sera le prix
proposé le même que pour une entreprise
de 1000 employés certainement pas
prenons mais moi je vous ai écouté enfin
et vous pouvez m'écouter aussi un
argument atttion qui est pas la vôtre
prenons justement l'exemple de
ProBTP ce régime de prévoyance intégré
protège les salariés en calculant leurs
droits même s'ils changent d'entreprise
comment faire cela avec la liberté
totale des entreprises de contracter ou
non une prévoyance en segmentant le
marché nous diminuons la couverture des
plus faibles ou des plus petites
entreprises pensons par exemple salariés
des particuliers employeurs s' n'était
pas couvert par une prévoyance négociée
par la branche il y aurait plus de
prévoyance tout simplement sincèrement
mes chers collègues nous devons
dépassionner ce débat car cette passion
je pense nous aveugle sur les véritables
enjeux pour des millions de salariés qui
bénéficient aujourd'hui de garantiese de
prévoyance alors je peux comprendre tout
à fait comprendre que certains ne soient
pas satisfaits d'un certain nombre de
points mais je dirais de grâce ne
brûlons pas toute la maison car ce
serait catastrophique la commission des
affaires sociales donc a donner un avis
défavorable sur l'ensemble des
amendements de suppression qui viennent
d'être
présentés merci monsieur le rapporteur
général madame la ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement sur ces quatre amendements
identiques merci monsieur le Président
un avis évidemment
défavorable je reprends entièrement à
mon compte les explications excellente
qui viennent d'être donné par monsieur
le rapporteur général mais de quoi
parlons-nous et parlons-nous euh d'un
dispositif celui qui avait été introduit
dans la loi transposant laannie
parlons-nous d'un dispositif entièrement
nouveau dans notre système juridique qui
n'existait pas qui viendrait bouleverser
le contexte dans lequel nous évoluons
évidemment non évidemment non parce que
le le Conseil constitue qu'a fait la ni
et la loi transposant la ni la ni a
prévu que l'ensemble des salariés et pas
simplement ceux des grandes entreprises
pour lesquelles c'est déjà le cas que
l'ensemble des salariés pourrait
bénéficier d'une couverture
complémentaire santé et éventuellement
de contrat
prévoyance pour faciliter l'accès de
l'ensemble des salariés à un coût
abordable abordable pour les salariés et
pour les entreprises
il a été prévu proposé de mettre en
place une clause de désignation cette
clause de désignation aboutissait à ce
que la branche indiquait ce qu'était le
contrat qui devait être retenu par les
entreprises membres de la branche est-ce
que ce dispositif est sorti de la poche
ou du de la tête de ceux qui ont
travailler soit dans le cadre de l'an
soit dans le cadre de la loi bien sûr
que non bien sûr que non puisqu'il s'est
simplement agi d'étendre un dispositif
législatif qui existait depuis 25 ans
qui existe dans le code qui existait
dans le code et qui a été introduit dans
notre droit par Madame Simone veille
alors ministre d'État en charge des
affaires sociales ce dispositif que ce
dont nous n'avions pas l'habitude c'est
que le Conseil d'État au lieu d'annuler
la disposition de la loi qui venait
d'être votée a non seulement annulé la
disposition de la loi mais il a annulé
ce qu'on pourrait appeler la disposition
source c'est-à-dire le premier
dispositif prévoyant la mise en place
d'une clause de désignation et donc les
clauses de désignation qui
fonctionnaient pour la santé et pour la
prévoyance surtout dans un certain
nombre de secteurs se sont toutes
trouvées
annulées ce que nous nous proposons ça
n'est pas de réintroduire une clause de
désignation et et de rendre obligatoire
le dispositif tel qu'il existait c'est
de s'inspirer de l'esprit de ce qui
avait été voulu y compris par Madame
veille au moment de la loi de 94 et au
fond de dire nous devons favoriser
l'accès des salariés à une bonne
couverture complémentaire santé et
prévoyance j'insiste sur ce point et
nous devons pour cela permettre que des
entreprises puissent être orienté euh
puissent puissent être informé sur des
contrats et puissent le cas échéant
bénéficier de contrats qu'on leur
indique pourquoi parce que quand vous
avez une entreprise qui a 10 salariés ça
n'est pas un des géants du CAC 40 qui de
toute façon couvre de manière tout à
fait satisfaisante et nous le savons
très bien l'ensemble de ces salariés à
la fois pour la santé et pour la
prévoyance et donc l'idée elle est là
c'est de faire une recommandation cette
recommandation pour être valable elle
doit it comporter des actions qui ont
été évoquées du type de Cell qui ont été
évoquées par monsieur le rapporteur
général c'estàdire qu'il suffit pas de
dire on va prendre en
charge disons des des frais dentaires
des frais optiques il faut aussi
proposer des mesures de solidarité de
l'accompagnement en terme de prévoyance
par exemple en cas de décès d'un parent
le soutien pour les études d'un enfant
une meilleure prise en charge sanitaire
et cetera et cetera et pour faciliter la
lecture entre les différents contrats on
introduit une variation du forfait
social et je réponds maintenant
précisément à deux questions qui ont été
évoqué sinon posé évidemment cette
disposition a tout àoir dans un PLFSS
puisqu'elle a pour vocation d'apporter
des recettes à la sécurité sociale donc
nous ne parlons pas simplement de
l'équilibre des régimes complémentaires
nous parlons de recettes pour la
sécurité sociale donc ça n'est pas du
tout d'un cavalier social dont nous
débattons à quel hauteur monsieur Milon
ces recettes sont-elles espérées
évidemment nous ne le saurons vraiment
que expost on peut considérer c'est en
tout cas un objectif que nous avons que
ces recettes devraient être autour de 20
millions d'euros entre 20 et 30 millions
si le dispositif était très largement
adopté mais en tout cas 20 million
d'euros qui représenterait une adhésion
satisfaisante mais loin de de de de
renvoyer à l'ensemble des entreprises de
notre pays donc vous voyez nous ne
faisons pas l'hypothèse du tout que il y
aurait un caractère automatique de
l'adhésion au contrat proposé monsieur
le sénateur et donc pour cette raison je
donne pour l'ensemble de ces raisons je
donne un avis défavorable à ces
amendements en insistant sur un point
qui a été souligné par monsieur le
rapporteur général c'est que l'esprit de
l'anis c'était vraiment de permettre la
couverture de tous les salariés de notre
pays et aujourd'hui euh parce
qu'aujourd'hui les salariés des grandes
entreprises sont très correctement
couverts et il s'agit de permettre aux
entreprises aux petites entreprises
d'apporter à leurs salariés des
garanties identiques à ceux dont
bénéficient les salariés des grandes
entreprises c'est aussi un principe
d'égalité et de justice auquel nous
sommes
attachés merci madame la ministre nous
passons aux explications de vote madame
procacia
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre bah je vous admire pour la
solidarité dont vous fait preuve à
l'égard du ministre du Travail qui avait
déjà essayé de nous faire passer dans la
ni cette dans le projet de loi la cet
accord cette Annie mais pour mémoire ce
n'était absolument pas ce qui avait été
négocié et ce qui avait été négocié
entre les partenaires sociaux et le
gouvernement n'était pas cette clause de
désignation heureusement annulé grâce à
notre recours par le Conseil
constitutionnel et les clauses de
recommandation impérative que vous nous
proposez aujourd'hui dans ce texte sont
des clauses de désignation qui sont
complètement camouflés enfin pas
complètement camouflé puisqueun certain
nombre de personnes y compris dans vos
rangs euh une sénatrice du Finistère ou
monsieur rveas député PS du finisterère
président de la commission des lois à
l'Assemblée nationale ou Monsieur
Bernard Poignant disent bien que sur ce
dispositif la pertinence du lien entre
le contenu de l'amendement et le texte
qui l'accueille n'est pas immédiate
préjudiciable et risque d'entraîner une
censure du Conseil constitutionnel ce
n'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont ceux
qui soutiennent le gouvernement les
dispositions de cet article 12 sont
provocquantes pour moi elles
introduisent une discrimination fiscale
et elles pent atteinte à la liberté
contractuelle et à la liberté des
entreprises en plus les remarque que
vous faites sur le fonctionnement de
l'assurance que ce soit vous madame la
ministre ou monsieur le rapporteur
montre que vous ne maîtrisez pas
complètement les mécanismes de
l'assurance qui sont certes complexes
mais ces mécanismes de l'assurance font
que vous allez mettre en jeu justement
la concurrence et c'est cette
concurrence qui permet de faire baisser
les prix alors excusez-moi votre
collègue monsieur Amon dans la loi sur
la consommation nous dit plus de
concurrence plus de concurrence et on
doit pouvoir résilier quand on veut tous
les contrats d'assurance au bout d'un an
sans même envoyer une lettre recommandée
et vous vous nous dites l'inverse donc
en matière d'ASS assurange le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est qu'au
gouvernement il n'y a pas une ligne
directrice qui est vraiment très nette
euh monsieur notre euh rapporteur enfin
notre intervenant monsieur Cardou vous a
bien bien évoquer le problème des règles
de financement du paritarisme parce qu'à
l'heure actuelle 90 % des clause de
désignation permettront aux mêmes
institutions de prévoyance d'obtenir ses
contrat et qui seront gérés par les
syndicats est-ce que ce n'est pas juste
avant le texte que nous annonce le
ministre de travail sur la
représentation syndicale sur le dialogue
social sur la formation professionnelle
simplement un moyen de calmer les
partenaires sociaux pour ma part et
j'interviens en mon nom propre et non
pas au nom du groupe UMP sur ce point en
tout cas je m' je m'interroge enfin vous
l'avez vu hier c'est cette disposition
va mettre en danger 30 à 40000 emplois
est-ce que dans la situation de la
France à l'heure actuelle on peut se
permettre de mettre en jeu encore 30 ou
40000 emplois non vraiment vraiment pas
quant aux caus quant aux clauses que
nous évoquait monsieur le rapporteur je
peux vous dire qu'un certain nombre de
compagnies d'assurance je ne citerai pas
mais c'était une des plus grandes qui
propose exactement les mêmes garanties
que l'organisme qui a été désigné par la
CCN transport est peut-être un tarif
moindre donc vous êtes en train
d'augmenter les prix et vous allez
augmenter les prix et donner le monopole
à un certain nombre d'entreprises
d'assurance et vous n'irez absolument
pas dans le sens qui était celui que
vous
recherchiez merci la parole est à Madame
Debray merci monsieur le Président
Madame les minist ch collègue je vais
pas revenir sur tout ce qu'a dit
excellemment ma collègue Catherine
procassia je n'ai pas une virgule à
changer sur ce qu'elle a dit je suis en
accord à 100 % sur tout ce qu'elle a dit
je vais revenir juste sur une chose
madame la ministre concernant votre la
taxation que vous mettez en place vous
nous vous nous avez parlé il y a
quelques semaines ou il y a quelques
jours d'une taxe je je vous cite presque
mais de mémoire d'une taxe incitative
qui n'aura qu'un impact infime sur les
comptes de la Sécurité sociale c'est que
vous avez dit à plusieurs reprises et
aujourd'hui vous nous dites qu'au
contraire c'est quelque chose
d'important qui apportera des recettes
et que c'est pour ça que ça toute sa
place dans ce projet de loi alors là
encore il y a il y a il y a deux poids
de mesurees une un jour vous nous dites
que ça n'aura pratiquement pas d'impact
sur la sécurité sociale et aujourd'hui
vous nous dites ça a c'est pour ça que
c'est sur dans cette loi donc j'avoue
que j'ai un petit peu de mal à
comprendre d'autre part quand le Conseil
constitutionnel a effectivement
invalider cette mesure je ne vois pas
pourquoi on essaie de rerentrer par la
fenêtre alors alors que on a été sorti
par la porte et enfin la troisième chose
la concurrence de notre pays a toujours
eu un impact positif sur les prix votre
collègue Amon comme l'a effectivement
très justement fait remarquer Catherine
procassia nous le dit à longueur de
journée et vous aujourd'hui vous nous
dites le contraire donc c'est vrai que
en matière d'assurance comme a dit très
justement un de mes collègues
l'assurance de la parole dans dans ce
gouvernement n'est pas au
rendez-vous merci chers collègue
monsieur de
César
oui je voulais apporter quelques
précisions par rapport à l'intervention
de madame la ministre lors du débat sur
Laan sur projet de loi an nous n'étions
pas opposés les écologistes à une
recommandation de branche c'est-à-dire
qu'il y ait une recommandation et comme
ça avait été discuté par les partenaires
sociaux c'est-à-dire que il puisse y
avoir une discussion au niveau de la
branche avec une mutuelle et de dire
voici un contrat avantageux qu'on
propose à toutes les personnes de la
branche nous n'étions pas opposés à une
recommandation nous étions opposé à
l'obligation et c'est ce qui avait fait
débat c'est le premier point le second
vous dites aujourd'hui ils sont libres
de faire oui mais enfin il y a une
taxation importante pour ceux qui le
font pas donc c'est une liberté
surveillée ou c'est une liberté
conditionnelle donc ce n'est pas
exactement un libre choix on va dire
c'est quand même une forte orientation
vous dites a solidarité de branche
certes il y a une solidarité dans la
branche mais entre branches il y a pas
de solidarité je voulais je l'ai
expliqué lors de l'explication sur
l'article j'ai dit justement comme ce
sont des mutualisations par branche et
il y a des branches qui sont plus euh
composés de cadres sans grand risque et
qui ne seront pas solidaires justement
avec ce que vous avez dit c'est le BTP
et donc il y a effectivement une
solidarité dans la branche par la
mutualisation imposée mais il n'y a pas
une solidarité interbranche et de la
même manière comme je l'ai précisé tout
à l'heure il y aurait pas la solidarité
aussi avec les gens qui ne sont pas dans
des branches les inactifs les retraités
les chômeurs et cetera et cetera donc
votre solidarité dont vous parlez n'est
que partielle on dirait pas je n'iraai
pas jusqu'à dire corporatiste mais on
pourrait le penser on pourrait y arriver
c'est-à-dire que c'est par branche mais
ce n'est pas interbranche et ce n'est
avec le reste de la population et pour
terminer je défends la valeur de
proximité imaginons qu'il y ait une
mutuelle qui donne pas satisfaction au
niveau des services et bien par contre
il peut y avoir une petite entreprise
qui connaît bien dans son village je ne
dirais pas breton pour pas exacerber
mais dans un village d'une rural qui
connaît bien justement le courtier
l'assureur il ne pourra pas faire avec
le courtier
l'assureur le contrat il sera obligé
sous peine de taxation financière plus
importante il sera obligé de de de faire
appel à la mutuelle même si le service
n'est pas le même donc en défendant la
valeur de proximité et bien on doit
permettre aux entreprises de pouvoir
choisir une personne ou un courtier ou
une entreprise de
proximité je ne dis pas qu'il ne doit
pas y avoir des recommand de branche la
branche peut négocier un excellent
contrat elle peut leoser à l'ensemble
des gens de la
branche ce sur quoi n nous nous opposons
ce n'est pas sur la recommandation c'est
sur l'obligation qui n'en est pas
vraiment une mais qui est quand même une
forte incitation puisqu'il y a une sorte
de pénalité
financière merci chers collègues
monsieur
hon
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues quelques
explications de vote d'abord madame la
ministre euh je dois dire que je viens
d'assister au de au travers pardon
de votre explication un grand numéro de
rétropédalage et je dis ça notamment
parce que je me souviens de la
discussion que nous avons eu dans cette
enceinte au mois de février au mois de
février vous nous expliquiez que la
clause de désignation c'était le
meilleur des mondes qui était promis à
l'ensemble des salariés dans les
branches professionnelles et puis
surtout puisque j'avais l'occasion déjà
à cette époque de on va dire porter les
enjeux du débat vous étiez resté plutôt
évasive sur certaines interrogations
notamment euh qui sont faites entre la
couverture santé et la couverture
prévoyance et aujourd'hui pourquoi vous
faites du rétropédalage d'abord vous
faites appel à Simone veille c'est c'est
assez exceptionnel là aussi quand on ne
sait plus à quel in se vouer on essaie
de trouver une personne ou une
personnalité en l'occurrence madame
veille et CEN est une mais bien sûr pour
dire que oui mais chez voususs à une
époque bah oui on est fier de ce qui a
été fait par certains et puis je vais
même vous dire pour vous comme pour nous
quand on se trompe il faut avoir
l'humilité de se de se reprendre et en
tous les cas de modifier les choses
deuxème élément sur donc la question de
la complémentaire santé et la couverture
prévoyance c'est effectivement deux
choses différentes et vos arguments aux
uns aux autres monsieur le rapporteur ne
tiennent pas davantage je vais vous
expliquer simplement parce que vous le
savez peut-être et si vous le savez pas
ben je vais le faire brièvement en santé
bien finalement vous prenez vous
mutualisez en fonction d'un certain
nombre de paramètres en général ce sont
les personnes qui composent les collèges
salariés cadres et cetera de
l'entreprise et puis globalement la
dépense médicale dans le territoire
donné et dans le territoire hisir donné
quand vous êtes en région parisienne et
ben vous le savez les coûts les
honoraires pratiqués facturés n'ont rien
à voir par exemple avec au hasard un
département la meurtemiselle qui n'aura
rien à voir avec le département voisin
desvuges pourquoi parce que vous avez un
équilibre entre une consommation
médicale pour une population donnée et
par rapport à des prix pratiqués et donc
en recentralisant sous une forme
d'économie nouvellement administrée
autour quelque part des institutions de
prévoyance et ça a été bien dit et bien
vous avez une inflation de la dépense
parce que le la moyenne n'est plus
assurée par les territoires avec des
avantages et parfois des inconvénients
puisque il y a aussi des territoires je
le dis qui sont plus chers que d'autres
mais parce que ça obéit à un équilibre
un équipe qui se justifie et puis il y a
le deuxième volet que vous sortez là un
peu comme un lapin du chapeau qui est la
prévoyance c'est effectivement
indispensable donc nous continuons de
soutenir la volonté de mettre être à la
fois de la santé et de la prévoyance
pour tous et toutes dans toutes les
entreprises quel que soit leur taille et
je m'inscris à nouveau en faux par un
peu d'expérience sur ce que j'ai pu
entendre en disant dans les petites
entreprises c'est forcément plus cher
non non je vais vous dire pourquoi pas
systématiquement ni oui ni non parce que
là aussi c'est l'équilibre entre une
population la survenance d'un certain
nombre de sinistre on appelle ça comme
ça ou l'absence et c'est un peu comme
dans les acents du travail bah quand une
entreprise même de trois salariés a de
bons résultats et bien vous arrivez à
négocier de très bonnes conditions et
quand vous avez parce que les
entreprises dites du CAC 40 madame la
ministre réjouissons-nous d'avoir des
entreprises en France qui figurent au
CAC 40 il y a pas de honte on a besoin
de la richesse du développement et de la
croissance qui que nous amèent ces
entreprises enfin arrêtons c'est pas un
gros mot aujourd'hui d'entreprendre
c'est pas un gros mot d'avoir des
entreprises en France qui rayonnent se
développent et qui ont également
beaucoup de salariés enfin heureusement
honnêtement les salariés et les
entreprises ne sont pas ennemis les
salariés dans les entreprises quel que
soit leur statut ils sont là aussi parce
que un ils ont besoin de vivre deux
souvent ils s'y sentent bien parfois il
y a des il y a des litiges comme dans
toute société je voudrais simplement
qu'on n'oublie pas de rappeler ces
quelques éléments enfin et pour terminer
je dirais monsieur le rapporteur vous
nous avez dit à la fin de votre
intervention je me méfie il ne faut pas
que la passion vous aveugle mais moi la
passion ne m'aveugle pas c'est ma raison
qui me guide et une certaine expérience
qui me conduit une fois encore à vous
redire avec une douce et grande sérénité
que nous sommes complètement en
désaccord avec l'article que vous nous
proposez merci chers collègue monsieur
Laménie
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre et chers collègues
concernant cet amendement et adjoint
aussi à aux autres autres amendement
présentés par par des collègues je
rebondis aussi sur l'intervention de de
nos collègues du groupe mais aussi de
jour des cessar il a parlé de notion de
proximité moi je voudrais aussi le le
dire avec force la notion de de
proximité la notion de bon en
particulier pour les pour les
territoires ruraux parce que je crois
qu'à un moment donné les collègues ont
rappelé le nombre d'emplois en jeu le
nombre d'emplois menacés euh et c'est
vrai il y a des inquiétudes tout tout à
fait légitime qu' on été rappelés au
niveau des courtiers des des assureurs
et je crois qu'à un moment donné faut
voir aussi la la la réalité en face je
crois que actuellement l'emploi reste la
priorité numéro 1 ça a toujours été le
cas je crois que les
inquiétudes de ces des professions
concernées sont aussi tout à fait
légitime et pour le pour le monde rural
je crois qu'il faut rien négliger non
non plus je crois qu'on est aussi sur
ses B un certain nombre d'élus de de
départements plutôt ruraux et je crois
qu' il faut aussi les les soutenir et
justement ces amendements là de qui
visent la suppression de cet article
vont aussi dans un une perspective de de
de de réalisme et de bon
sens merci la parole est à Monsieur
Vat
oui cet article contesté reprend
l'article 1er de Laan censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel il prévoit
d'autoriser les branches à recommander
un ou plusieurs organismes d'assurance
complémentairire le ou les organismes
assureurs recommandé devant appliquer un
tarif unique à toutes les entreprises
offrir des garanties identiques à toutes
les entreprise et à tous les salariés
qui ne pourront refuser l'adhésion d'une
entreprise de la branche
ces précisions posent problème puisque
pour être efficace par nature un contrat
d'assurance complémentaire selon nous
doit coller au plus près aux besoins des
salariés en outre une entreprise qui
choisirait de ne pas appliquer la
recommandation serait assujettie à un
taux de forfait social de 20 % si elle
compte au moins 10 salariés ou 8 % si
elle en compte moins cela ça
ni plus ni moins du chantage ou en tout
cas faut dire que cela y ressemble
vraiment d'autant que l'on peut imaginer
aussi une situation le cas où une
entreprise refuserait tout simplement
parce que le comité d'entreprise alerte
l'employeur sur le fait que l'organisme
proposé dans la recommandation
proposerait un contrat moins protecteur
que celui dont il disposerait déjà enfin
les employeurs qui OPT pour une
entreprise recommandée seront
exonération exonérés de cotisation
sociale nous ne sommes pas d'accord on
fragilise ainsi la sécurité sociale de
base au profit de la protection
complémentaire qui peut être mutualiste
comme elle peut être privée commerciale
et compe de
l'opération le projet de loi de
financement pour
2014 prévoit de fiscaliser ses contrats
considérant pour les salariés
considérant qu'il s'agit d'un avantage
en nature pour eux qu'il faut réintégrer
dans le calcul dans l'assiette de
l'impôt sur le revenu donc pour toutes
ces raisons le groupe CRC qui avait voté
contre l'article 1 de la ni adoptera un
vote cohérent et donc votera pour les
amendements de
suppression très bien mes chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur
général merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
peut-être avant quelques éléments
d'appréciation comme Madame la Ministre
tout à l'heure un rappel historique
c'est par le biais des conventions
collectives nationales donc CCN que la
prévoyance collective s'est développé en
particulier par la convention collective
nationale des cadres de 1947
qui a imposé aux entreprises la
souscription de contrats couvrant les
cadres contre le risque décès à hauteur
de 15 % de leur rémunération
1947 les décennies suivantes ont vu une
majorité de convention collective
national imposer des niveaux de
couverture de prévoyance donc décès
incapacité invalidité à leurs
entreprises adhérentes et ce sont dans
les années 90 avec l'envol des
institutions de prévoyance loi de 1989
loi de 19 194 que sont apparus les
clauses de désignation qui obligent les
employeurs ne disposant pas déjà d'une
couverture à rejoindre un organisme
désigné et généralement la désignation
concerne un à trois organismes ou en
tout cas concerné un à trois organisme
et se baser donc sur l'article
l9121 du code de la sécurité sociale
avoir ceci en tête insister sur le fait
alors nous ne sommes pas d'accord n pas
une raison pour ne pas exprimer une
autre opinion
insister sur le fait que la
mutualisation des risques est un outil
qu'il faut impérativement mettre à
disposition des partenaires sociaux il
permet une gestion fine des risques une
baisse des coûts d'assurance la présence
systématique d'une participation
bénéfice dans les régimes mutualisés
rend inutile une compétition par le prix
et au final le prix payé est proche du
tarif d'équilibre alors oui oui les
accords de branche présente un certain
nombre d'avantages j'en rappellerai au
moins quatre regroupement dans un seul
cadre de l'ensemble des assurés
permettant un suivi de cette population
permettant des actions de prévention et
surtout une gestion fine des Invalides
pour le maintien de le de
leurevalorisation ou de leur garantie
d'essès mais aussi des entreprises qui
sont assurées de trouver un assureur
quel que soit l'état de santé de son
effectif des entreprises dont les
salariés sont plus âgés et ou plus
malades que la moyenne P le même tarif
que les autres et donc au final un
principal avantage qui réside dans la
nette diminution du prix pour les TPE et
les PME en conclusion de ceci que dire
il y a eu le débat sur l'ami le débat
loi de sécurisation donc quelques mois
plus tard ne refaisons pas ce débat sur
la ni qui été un débat sur les
complémentaires santé mesurons bien que
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
baller un champ beaucoup plus large que
celui qui était le champ de Laan et le
champ de la loi de sécurisation car la
décision du Conseil pas c'est pas fort
chez vous d'écouter hein de temps en
temps pas Laer par que vous que vous ne
soyez pas d'accord mais c'est votre
droit c'est démocratie en vous pouvez
laisser au moins une opinion contraire à
la votre vous êtes très majoritaire en
plus ici c'est exprimer ça me paraît
moindre des choses donc insistz sur le
fait insister sur le fait que la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
ballit un champ beaucoup plus large que
celui qui était le champ de Laan et de
la loi de sécurisation puisqueen fait il
vise toutes les clauses de désignation
qui existaient antérieurement et qui
continuaient d'exister au-delà de la loi
de l'an alors ne refaisons pas je dis ce
débat mesurons qu'il est important
aujourd'hui de préserver
des régimes de prévoyance intégré qui
existent qui sont performants qui sont
appréciés dans beaucoup de branches et
qui servent aujourd'hui parfaitement
l'intérêt des salariés la réponse
apportée par le gouvernement
certainement pas la meilleure
construction dans l'idéal mais elle
permet aujourd'hui de trouver au moins
une réponse à ce problème qui est posé
et qui je pense est un problème
important et qui mériterait d'être
regardé d'une autre façon que à travers
ces amend de
suppression merci chers collègues j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par les groupes UMP uduc
socialiste sur ces quatre
amendements je vous rappelle que l'avis
de la commission est défavorable l' viis
de Gouvernement est défavorable et nous
allons procéder au scrutin public selon
notre article
56 le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scutin est
ouvert
personne ne demande à
voter le scrutin est clos merci au
secrétaire de procéder au
dépouillement
mes chers collègues résultat du scrutin
numéro
47 nombre de votants
343 nombre de suffrage exprimés
343 pour l'adoption
217 contre
126 le Sénat a adopté ses amendement et
donc l'article 12 TER est
supprimé
nous revenons au cours normal de la
discussion des articles et j'appelle en
discussion l'amendement numéro 63
rectifié tendant à insérer un article
additionnel avant l'article 8 et c'est
monsieur le rapporteur général merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cet amendement je
pense de bon sens propose de faire
passer de 1 % à 0,9 % le taux de la
cotisation versée par les établissements
hospital
au titre du financement du fond pour
l'emploi hospitalier donc le
FH au terme des différents éléments
financiers en du public par la Caisse
des Dépôts et Consignation les comptes
du F sont en effet structurellement
excédentaires le fond a ainsi affiché un
résultat net supérieur à 30 millions
d'euros par an au cours des 5 derniers
exercices pour des dépenses de l'ordre
de 180 millions d'euros la diminution de
0,1 po proposé tente ainsi à alléger le
montant de la taxe pesant sur les
établissements hospitaliers au moment où
les comptes de ceux-ci sont
particulièrement contraints cette
diminminution devrait par ailleurs
préserver le caractère excédentaire des
comptes du FEH en dépit de la diminution
de ce taux ceci devrait présenter un
résultat net proche de 14 millions
d'euros fin 2014 et des réserves de 27
millions
d'euros merci Madame la Ministre l'avis
du Gouvernement sur cet amendement de la
commission
monsieur le rapporteur général je je
comprends bien la la préoccupation qui
est la vôtre et qui est de tenter de
cerner le juste niveau de la
contribution des du fond hospitalier et
des établissements hospitaliers au titre
du redressement de la CNRA cl
aujourd'hui le taux de cotisation le
taux de contribution de ces
établissements est fixé de manière
réglementaire et vous voulez l'inscrire
dans la loi moi je vous demanderais
plutôt de retirer cet amendement au
profit d'un travail que nous devons
engager et qui doit avancer en
concertation avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes nous ne savons pas si le taux
que vous proposez serait le taux qui
conviendrait précisément nous devons
évidemment permettre de garantir un fond
de roulement suffisant au FEH tout en
réduisant le déficit prévisionnel de la
caisse qui aujourd'hui reste trop
important néanmoins nous avons besoin de
répondre aux besoins de compétenenceces
des employeurs aux attentes des agents
nous avons besoin au fond de pouvoir
fixer avec une certaine souplesse le
niveau de cette juste contribution et de
la cotisation afférente et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous demanderai
pour que la concertation puisse engagé
de retirer votre amendement sinon je lui
donnerai un avis
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
général l'amendement est maintenu
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues donc
l'amendement a été adopté par la
commission donc pas tout à fait en
mesure à l'instant sur les éléments que
vous avez dit de le retirer
donc bien je vais donc mettre au voix
cet amendement par avant explication de
vote monsieur Milon
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
les ministre mes chers collègues nous
voterons cet amendement proposé par le
rapporteur général pour deux raisons
hier nous étions contre le fait que on
prélevait de l'argent à la FH pour la
donner à CNRC c'est qu'il y avait donc
trop de cotisation au niveau de FH et
cette diminution de taux de cotisation
est la seule qui existe dans ce PFS
PLFSS tout le reste augmente alors pour
une fois qu'on a une petite diminution
nous sommes
favorables merci pas d'autre explication
de vote je vais mettre au voix donc avis
favorable de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement
pour
contre
abstention l'amendement est
adopté toujours avant l'article 8
l'amendement 62 rectifié terre monsieur
Frassa merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
chers collègues l'article 29 de la loi
de finan rectificative pour 2012 soumet
au prélèvements sociaux au taux global
de 15 et demi pour pour les revenus
immobiliers revenus fonciers et
plusvalue immobilière de sources
françaises perçu par les personnes
physiques fiscalement domicilié hors de
France les revenus fonciers sont
désormais imposés aux prélèvements
sociaux dus sur les revenus du
patrimoine à un taux de 15,5 % et les
plusvalues immobilières sont imposés au
prélèvements sociaux sur les produits de
placement recouvrés à la source par
l'intermédiaire notamment des notaires à
l'instar des personnes fiscalement
domicil en France déjà assujettis à ses
prélèvements ces mesures s'ajoutent au
prélèvement déjà appliqués s'agissant de
l'imposition sur revenus et se sont
traduites pour les 60000 contribuables
concernés par une hausse d'imposition
moyenne de près de 4200 €. ces mesures
présentées au nom de
l'ununiversalité pardon des prélèvements
sociaux et de la cohérence de l'impôt
comportte nombre d'effets pervers en
premier lieu elles ont pour conséquence
de taxer les plus-values foncières à
près de 50 % ce qui rend les
investissements fonciers nettement moins
attractif que d'autres placements en
second lieu elle crée des risques de
double imposition i dès lors que les
revenus fonciers et les plusvalues
immobilières font parfois l'objet
conformément aux conventions fiscales en
vigueur d'une taxation du pays de
résidence ces mesures sont également
contraires au principe d'équité la
précédente majorité avait repoussé
l'idée d'un assugjétissement aux
cotisations sociales des plus-valu
foncière des non-résidents au motif que
ces derniers ne bénéficient pas des
prestations sociales financées par la
Sécurité Sociale enfin ces mesure ne
tenez pas compte du refus de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne d'étendre
la CSG et la CRDS au revenu de sources
française dès lors que ces nonrésidents
sont assujettis à une imposition sociale
dans un autre État membre après
consultation des autorité française sur
la conformité du droit européen de
l'extension de la CSG et de la CRDS au
revenus immobiliers perçus par les
nonrésidents procédure pilote euh la
direction générale de l'emploi des
affaires sociales et de l'inclusion de
la Commission européenne a clôturé le
dossier par un avis négatif une
procédure d'infraction contre la France
a été ouverte depuis le présent
amendement vise à revenir sur ce
mécanisme injuste et à préserver le
régime fiscal des expatriés alors que la
majorité souhaite progressivement
alourdir le régime comme le met en
évidence la proposition émise à la fin
de l'année 2012 visant à exiger des
Français établir de France le paiement
du différentiel entre l'impôt dont il
s'acquitte à l'étranger et ceux dont il
devrait s'acquitter en France l'adoption
de cet amendement constituerait un
signal positif fort vis-à-vis de nos
compatriotes expatriés je vous remercie
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur la la
commission monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement propose de revenir sur les
disposition de l'article 29 de la loi de
finances rectificative pour 2012
soumettant aux prélèvements sociaux
doncutau global de 155 nous avons tous
ça en tête maintenant les revenus
immobiliers revenus fonciers plusvalue
immobilière de sources françaises perçu
par les personnes physiques fiscalement
domicilier hors de France l'alignement
du régime social applicable au reven
revenu immobilier de sources françaises
perçu par les personnes physiques
fiscalement domicilié hors de France
avec celui des personnes fiscalement
domicilié sur le territoire me paraît
tout à la fois juste et équitable juste
puisqu'il porte sur des revenus de
nature identiques situés sur le
territoire national équitable puis qu'il
concerne l'ensemble des investisseurs
propriétaires de biens situés en France
et domiciliers hors de France cette
mesure concerne ainsi près de 60000
ménages bénéficiant en moyenne de 12000
€ par an de revenus fonciers sur les
biens situés en France au titre de loyer
qu'il s'agisse
d'investitteurinvestisseurs pardon
étranger sans lien particulier avec la
France
d'expatriés personnes actives ou
retraitées installées à l'étranger ayant
conservé des bien immobiliers en France
ou encore de frontalier qui habitent un
pays limitrophe travaill aant en France
affilié à la Sécurité Sociale française
et disposant d'une résidence secondaire
ou d'un bien mis en location en France
au vu de ces différents éléments la
commission a donné un avis défavorable à
l'amendement proposé merci Monsieur
rapporteur général monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
l'avis est le même que le rapporteur
général pour des raisons que je veux
évoquer rapidement d'abord je veux
rappeler que la mesure qui a été prise
par le gouvernement loi de finance
rectificative pour 2012 était une mesure
d'équité puisqu'elle visait à ce que
des contribuables soient traités de la
même manière qu'il soit ou non résidents
français il n'y a aucune raison que ne
s'applique pas les mêmes dispositifs
fiscaux à des personnes ressortissantes
françaises selon qu'elles sont ou non
situé en France enfin je veux insister
sur le fait fait que la mesure adoptée
l'an dernier s'applique aussi dans le
cadre de convention internationale et
soumet le revenus les revenus au
prélèvements sociaux pour autant que les
conventions internationales est réservé
à la France l'imposition des revenus de
sources immobilière ce qui est
généralement le cas en application du
principe de territorialité il n'y a donc
pas et il ne peut pas y avoir
contrairement à ce que vous avez indiqué
dans votre intervention de double
imposition s'agissant du droit
communautaire les arrêts que vous
mentionnez ne s'appliquent qui est
corevenu d'activité ce qui est légitime
s'agissant d'un droit communautaire
visant la coordination de régime de
sécurité sociale et notamment à éviter
le double assujettissement aux
cotisations sociales des revenus de
travail des travailleurs migrants ou
transfrontaliers la même lecture ne peut
s'appliquer à des revenus du patrimoine
le Conseil constitutionnel dans sa
décision du 9 août 2012 validant
l'article 29 de la loi de finance
rectificative pour 2012 que vous
souhaitez abroger par votre votre
amendement précise que les prélèvements
sociaux sur les revenus du capital sont
des impositions de toute nature et non
des cotisations sociales ces
prélèvements ne sont pas contributifs
ils n'ouvrre pas droit à des prestations
sociales ces revenus n'étant pas imposés
dans le tas de résidence du contribuable
il n'y a donc pas de double imposition
ce que le droit communautaire cherche à
éviter bien au contraire ne pas
assujétir ses revenus aboutirait à une
forme de double non imposition c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes pas
favorbles à cet amendement merci
monsieur le ministre je vais mettre au
voix cet amendement monsieur frerassa
explication de
vote merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur monsieur le
ministre j'ai bien entendu vos vos
remarques je pourrais à la limite les
les comprendre mais ce qui me désole un
peu c'est que nous sommes dans un pays
qui n'arrive pas à tirer les
conséquences de jurisprudence européenne
vous me parlez de l'arrêt du Conseil
constitutionnel qui n'aura aucune force
face à une décision de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne
vous me parlez de problématiqu qui ne
tiennent pas compte et je vous parle
d'expérience puisque j'ai été partie
civile dans l'arrêt de 2000 donc et j'ai
l'impression de faire un grand bond de
20 ans en arrière puisqueen 2004 lorsque
nous avons initié la plainte contre
l'État français sur la cgcrds applicable
au revenu du travail on nous disait mais
non tout est bordé mais non enfin nous
avons réfléchi enfin l'administration
fiscale a si bien réfléchi qu'elle
commet 20 ans plus tard la même erreur
et moi je trouve un pe navrant que ce
soit la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne de faire mettre un deuxième
genou à terre à la France en lui en lui
mettant en la mettant en face de cette
évidence c'est que pour l'Union
européenne la c la CRDS sont des
cotisations sociales l'administration
fiscale seule contre vs et Maré
maintient que ce sont des impôts et bien
on attendra donc la décision de la Cour
de justice de l'Union européenne et
finalement ça coûtera plus cher à l'État
qui devra rembourser les sommes indument
perçu tant pis moi je maintiens
l'amendement pas d'autre explication de
vote je mets au voix cet amendement 82
rectifi TER qui est
favorablez vous AES combien là il 19
c'est ça qui est
contre
19 19 assis debout je suis désolé qui
est
favorable
merci 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18
19 20 20 qui est
contre 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
14 15 16 17 18 19 20
20 20 voix pour 20 voix contre il n'est
pas
adopté amendement numéro
162 monsieur Vatin madame
Pasquet merci monsieur le président cet
amendement a pour objet de renforcer la
fiscalité sociale sur le trait de
chapeau c'est-à-dire ces mécanismes de
rémunération complémentairire qui
profitent essentiellement à une minorité
de cadres dirigeants et aux salariés qui
sont déjà faut-il le rappeler parmi les
mieux rémunérés cette mesure nous
apparaît d'autant plus légitime que le
Conseil constitutionnel à la suite de
l'adoption par la loi de finances de
2013 à supprimé la tranche marginale à
21 % de manière à mener la taxation
marginale pesant sur les retraites
chapeau à 68,34 %. naturellement nous
déplorons l'analyse faite par le Conseil
constitutionnel qui se place dans une
logique purement fiscale et auert
totalement l'aspect solidaire de cette
mesure il y a de quoi faire puisque en
plus des bonus stock option et action
gratuit la moitié des patrons du CAC40
bénéficie d'une retraite chapeau dont
dont un grand hebdomadaire nous
apprenait l'année dernière à la même
époque que ces mécanismes particuliers
leur permettaient de bénéficier d'une
rente moyenne de
545000 € qui vient s'ajouter à la
pension du régime obligatoire tout cela
conduit à ce que au final un PDG
retraité reçoivent 41 fois la pension
d'un retraité Français estàdire et nous
sommes au groupe CRC convaincus de
l'inverse que les cadres dirigeants
produisent 41 fois plus de richesse que
les salariés les les les entreprises en
difficulté contrairement à ce que l'on
pourrait croire ne sont pas en reste
loin sans fou dans le cadre de leur
rapport sur le sauvetage coûteux de la
banque francobge les magistrats de la
Cour des comptes ont épluché les
rémunérations versées chez Dexia y
compris après qu'elle ait été renflouée
à coût de fonds publics et les résultats
sont particulièrement intéressants
puisqu'on y apprend que six dirigeants
français de la banque en poste jusqu'en
2008 ont perçu d'importantes retra
chapeau ainsi Pierre Richard l'ancien
patron opérationnel de Dexia aperçu à la
fois une retraite retraite au titre de
la fonction publique une rémunération
400000 € en 2006 et en 2007 en tant que
président de du conseil d'administration
et une rente de
563750 € puis 300000 € au titre de sa
retraite chapeau rente réduite de moitié
au terme d'un accord signé le 13 mars
mars 2013 après que le conseil
d'administration a décidé fin 2012
d'engager un recours contre son ancien
président il ne s'agit là que d'un
exemple mais qui nous confirme dans
l'idée que nous nous faisons de
l'utilité d'adopter une telle
mesure merci chers collègues l'avis de
la commission monsie rapporteur
général monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement vise à supprimer
l'exonération de CSG et de cotisation
sociale prévu pour les contributions des
employeurs au financement des régimes de
retraite dit chapeau les avantages
donnés à certains de nos compatriotes
par le biais des retraites chapeau ont
déjà ces dernières années été largement
rectifié les retraites chapeau relevant
du code de la sécurité sociale subissent
une contribution d par l'employeur
laquelle a été doublée par l'article 32
de la loi de finance rectificative pour
2012 les taux sont maintenant de 24 %,
32 % 48 % selon selon la catégorie de
retraite chapeau une contribution
additionnelle d par l'employeur de 30 %
à partir de plafonds d'assécurité
sociale et une contribution à la charge
du bénéficiaire s'ajoute à l'impôt sur
le revenu et aux contributions sociales
dont les taux ont été modifié en loi de
finance pour 2012 et vont jusqu'à 21 %
de la rente au total donc le taux de
prélèvement global est déjà élevé me
paraît pas à cet instant opportun
d'aller plus loin la commission a donné
un avis défavorable à cet amendement
merci avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Députée les madame la sénatrice pardon
excusez-moi les contributions
spécifiques sur les retraites chapeau à
la charge de l'employeur à la charge du
bénéficiaire de ces retraites ont
précisément pour objet effet de
compenser l'absence de cotisation
sociale et de CSG CRDS sur le
financement par l'emploi employeur de
ses avantages en effet la contribution
de l'employeur aux retraite chapeau ne
peut pas faire l'objet d'un prélèvement
à la charge du salarié car ces avantages
au stade de leur financement par
l'employeur ne sont ni certaines pour le
bénéficiaire ni individualisé et il ne
le deviennent qu'au moment du départ en
retraite c'est pourquoi il existe une
contribution spécifique sur les rentes à
la charge du bénéficiaire qui vise à
rattraper l'absence de CSG sur le
financement de l'employeur ce mécanisme
exclut la possibilité d'assujettir à des
prélèvements sociaux comme la CAG les
sommes que l'employeur consacre à
l'acquisition de garantie c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous ne pouvons pas
être favorabl à cet
amendement merci explication de vote
Monsieur
deessard Je pis voter l'amendement
défendé par les collègues
du groupe CRC maintenant monsieur le
ministre a amené une précision et
j'aimerais lui
demander quel est l'écart est ce qu'il
dit ils ne peuvent pas payer deux fois
ils peuvent pas être assujettis à la CSG
et autres prélèvement parce que ils le
sont déjà par ailleurs est-ce que je
peux avoir un ord d'idée ù est-ce que
c'est le plus
intéressant parce que si c'est moins
intéressant actuellement que la
proposition de l'amendement du de mes
collègues ben je vais quand même choisir
le plus intéressant enfin faut bien
trouver un peu de l'argent j'ai
l'impression qu'on est en période de
rigueur de difficulté et là on tape pas
les plus les moins riches puisque ce
sont des retraites chapeau pas des
retraites plancher donc moi j'avais
l'impression que si le la position
commune proposée par le groupe par mes
collègues était plus intéress ente que
celle qui existe actuellement je pensais
qu'il y avait une certaine comme s dit
dans la défense de l'amendement une
certaine justice sociale à mettre au
même niveau les plus haut les plus
grosses retraites par rapport aux
petites retraites
voilà merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le sénateur les la
surtaxe au titre des retraites chapeau
est comprise entre 7 et 14 %
et prélèvement au titre de la CG de 7 %
donc vous voyez que la proposition du
gouvernement
n'est pas de d'avantager ceux qui
bénéficient de ces
dispositifs je vais mettre au voix cette
amendement
162 du groupe CRC avec avis défavorable
de la commission avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est
pour
contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté avant
l'article 8 amendement 163 monsieur
Vatin à la différence du gouvernement le
constat que nous faisons et que notre
système de protection sociale souffre
moins de ces dépenses que d'une
insuffisance chronique de recettes
preuve en est le fait que
progressivement la dépense sociale temps
a diminué ainsi comme le rappelait le
comité d'annulation pour la dette
publique relativement bien sûr la prise
en charge des dépenses de soins de
médicaments par la Sécurité Sociale est
passée de plus de 80 % à la fin des
années 70 à 75,5 % en 2009 de plus en
plus de personnes sont aujourd'hui
exclus de l'accès aux soins or en
adoptant le traité européen pour la
stabilité la coordination et la
gouvernance vous avez fait votre
monsieur le ministre ce discours libéral
je pourrais même dire ultra libéral de
réduction de la dépense plutôt que celui
de l'accroissement des ressources
puisque désormais le TSCG impose de
renier sur les dépenses sociales en cas
de dépassement d'un déficit structurel
de 0,5 % à l'inverse de ce schéma il
nous semble important de renforcer le
financement de la sécurité sociale ses
recettes et pour reprendre une formule
chère au gouvernement dans la justice
c'est ce que nous proposons par cet
amendement qui tente augmenter de 5
points le taux des prélèvements sociaux
sur les revenus du patrimoine et les
produits de placement financier sous la
forme d'une contribution additionnelle
de l'aveu même de Monsieur bapte en
séance publi à l'Assemblée nationale
répondant un amendement identique de
notre collègue Jacqueline fres je cite
le taux global des prélèvements sociaux
sur les revenus du capital est
actuellement de 15 et5i % autrement dit
contrairement à ce que l'on entend trop
souvent les prélèvements sociaux sur les
revenus du capital sont nettement
inférieurs à ceux opérés sur les revenus
du travail à l'inverse ce que l'on
constate c'est que les salariés les
retraités voient croître dans des
proportions considérables les
prélèvements opérés sur les salaires et
les pensions plus de 70 milliards
d'euros ponctionnés au titre de la sol
CRDS or cette crise de sous-financement
profite d'abord et avant tout au marchés
financiers et à la spéculation puisque
pour ne prendre que se seul exemple
l'obligation faite à la cadesse
d'emprunter sur les marchés financiers
constitue une manne pour les banques et
les fonds spéculatifs ceci ont engrangé
en 2011 par exemple plus de 38 milliards
d'euros au titre des intérêts et
commissions donc pour toutes ces raisons
je vous propose d'adopter cet amendement
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur général avis de la
commission merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre chers collègues cet
amendement propose de créer deux
nouvelles contributions additionnelles
sur les revenus du patrimoine et les
produits de placement dont le produit
serait affecté à la branche maladie du
régime général il s'agit de doubler par
le biais de la création de deux
contributions additionnelles le taux des
prélèvements sociaux assis sur les
revenus donc du patrimoine et les
produits de placement nous pouvons être
sensible un produit attendu de ces taxe
entre 5 et 6 milliards d'euros en 2014
selon l'exposé des motifs mais les
mesures proposée ou la mesure proposée
paraît toutefois excessive la commission
des affaires sociales a donné un avis
défavorable à l'amendement merci avis
défavorable madame monsieur le
ministre monsieur le sénateur le
Gouvernement est défavorable à cet
amendement pour des raisons que je vais
expliquer brièvement d'abord comme vous
le savez les taux de prélèvements
sociaux sur les produits d'éparne ont
considérablement augmenté entre 2009 et
2012 puisqueen 2009 le taux des
prélèvements sociaux sur l'épargne était
de l'ordre de 10 % et qu'en l'espace de
quelques années il est passé à 5
%. il m'est arrivé d'ailleurs d'entend
des orateurs de votre groupe dans un
autre
assemblée expliquer que la mesure
d'harmonisation des taux de prélèvement
sur les pines que nous avons proposé
dont il sera question j'imagine
dans le débat sur l'article suivant
était une manière de prélèvement sur
l'épargne des Français qui ne se
justifiait pas alors que cette mesure ne
correspond ni à une taxe nouvelle ni à
une augmentation de taux sur les
prélèvements sociaux de au titre des
produits d'épargne et que cette décision
d'augmenter les prélèvements sociaux sur
les produits d'épargne a été prise entre
9009 et 2012 avec une augmentation très
significative du taux qui a conduit à un
prélèvement sur ces produits d'épargne
de 6 milliards et il ne s'agit pas
simplement de produits d'épargne détenu
ou de placement capitaux détenus par des
contribuables très
fortunés de nombreux contribuables qui
ont de
petits P de petits PEA ou de petits
contrat d'assurance vie était concerné
par cette augmentation massive des
prélèvements sociaux sur les produits de
placement ce que vous proposez c'est de
les augmenter encore de façon
significative si nous le fais nous
toucherions de façon indifférenciée des
éparnants quel que soit le niveau de
leur de leur revenus ou leur capacité
contributive je ne suis pas sûr que la
mesure serait juste deuxièmement je suis
assuré qu'elle ne serait pas
constitutionnelle parce que compte tenu
des décisions récentes du Conseil
constitutionnel sur les taux marginaux
d'imposition il y a fort à parier qu'une
augmentation aussi massive de niveau des
prélèvements sur lespne par une
augmentation aussi significative des
taux serait condamné par le Conseil
constitutionnel pour ces deux raisons je
je suis défavorable à cet amendement
merci je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement 163 pas d'explication de vote
qui est
pour
contre abstention il n'est pas
adopté sur l'article 8 demande de parole
de madame Isabelle
Debray merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues l'article 8 du
projet deit financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2014 réforme les modalités
de calcul des prélèvements sociaux
appliqués à certains produits de
placement exonéré d'impôt sur le revenu
précisément il est prévu que les
plusu-values constituées depuis le 1er
janvier
1997 seront soumises au taux unique de
15,5 %. tout d'abord je voudrais
souligner combien il me semble
parfaitement inéquitable de modifier les
les règles du jeu en cours de route les
Français à l'époque ont fait confiance à
l'état pour investir à long terme et
voici qu'une fois encore l'état revient
sur ses engagements comment voulez-vous
que les Français retrouve cette
confiance que le Président de la
République appelle de ses vœux par voie
de conséquence les épargnants devront
faire face à l'augmentation des
contributions sociales du sur les gains
de leur placement
souscouvert d'une mesure technique
habillée de bons sentiments le
gouvernement procède ni plus ni moins à
un holdup et je pèse mes mots sur
l'épargne des Français non content
d'avoir alourdi la fiscalité de près de
60 milliards d'euros depuis le début du
quinquena vous entendez poursuivre votre
politique de prélèvement tous aimut sans
le moindre discernement alors que les
Français sont aujourd'hui victime d'une
overdose fiscale certains dans votre
majorité semblent en avoir pris
conscience bien que tardivement c'est
ainsi que juste après avoir fait voter à
l'Assemblée nationale le taux unique de
15,5 % applicable à la plupart des
produits de placement des voies se sont
élevées dans votre propre famille
politique pour demander que l'épargne
populaire le Peel et l'épargne salariale
soi
préservé le rapport le rapporteur pardon
du PLFSS lui-même Gérard bat a opéré une
volte face en exprimant le souhait que
des corrections puissent être apporté à
l'occasion de l'examen du texte au Sénat
puis ce fut au tour du Premier ministre
de vouloir faire marche arrière et de
demander au ministre de l'économie et du
budget monsieur Moscovici et à vous-même
monsieur casaznu des améliorations en ce
qui concerne le régime des prélèvements
sociaux sur les comptes et plans
d'épargne logement et que dire de la
prochaine réforme de l'assur VI présenté
ce mercredi en Conseil des ministres
avec cette réforme vous avez l'ambition
d'orienter l'épargne de nos compatriotes
vers les entreprises notamment les PME
et les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire parfait vous mettez en
avant des incitations fiscales qui ne
sont d'ailleurs pas encore très
clairement définies et risque même
d'être très décevante pour promouvoir
ces nouveaux produits de placement mais
alors pourquoi proposez-vous dans ce pl
SS d'alourdir les contributions sociales
sur des supports d'épargne qui pour
certains servent au financement de notre
économie et de nos entreprises
comprennent qui pourra bref ce
gouvernement agit une fois encore dans
la précipitation et
l'impréparation la vérité c'est que les
Français sont éintés et n'en peuvent
plus d'être ponctionnés chaque jour
davantage la vérité c'est que leur
pouvoir d'achat diminue de manière
dramatique 2012 ayant été je le rappelle
l'année où le recul du pouvoir d'achat
de nos concitoyens a été le plus fort
depuis
1984 alors que vous étiez aux affaires à
cette époque cruelle répétition de
l'histoire la vérité c'est que ce sont
toujours les mêmes qui pr le qui paient
le prix de votre politique les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes
pourtant ceux qui contre b
majoritairement à l'effort de
redressement des comptes de la
Nation certes conscient de la crise les
Français sont prêt à fournir
d'importants efforts mais en
contrepartie de ces efforts ils
attendent une politique claire équitable
et
stable quand vous déciderez-vous à
engager les vraies réformes
structurantes celle qui constitue à
réduire drastiquement les dépenses à
alléger le poids des normes et à réduire
des transferts sociaux toujours plus
élevés qui sont autant de primes dédié à
la sistana plutôt que d'aller vers la
facilité en ponctionnant encore une fois
nos concitoyens sur leurs économies
souvent acquises au prix de sacrifice
les faits sont têtu et la France dont la
note vient d'être dégradée par l'agence
de notation standards and pours ne peut
s'exonérer d'une véritable révolution
quant aux méthodes et moyens de son
redressement vous l'avez compris le
groupe um s'oppose à cet article et
présentera un amendement de suppression
je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre voulez la
parole vous l'avez
oui monsieur le Président je me permets
de prendre la parole maintenant parce
que comme ce débat va être riche dansse
et et
interactif je préférerais que dès le
début de notre échange nous soyons sûr
de parler de la même chose et je me
permet madame la sinatrice d'intervenir
parce que un certain nombre de choses
que vous avez
ditesres je suis convaincu de vosre
sincérité à ce que vous croyez mais
absolument pas la réalité donc je vais
m'expliquer très précisément d'abord
quelle est la mesure que nous avons
prise la mesure que nous avons prise
n'est pas du tout une mesure qui
consiste à créer une taxe supplémentaire
sur l'épargne ce n'est pas une mesure
qui consiste à créer un nouvel impôt ou
augmenter un taux sur des produits
d'épargne pas du tout le taux c'est vous
qui l'avez augmenté entre 2009 et 2012
je veux donner des choses extrêmement
précises madame la sénatrice qui vont
vous rassurer tout à fait quant à nos
intentions et vous permettre de faire de
façon rétrospective un petit examen du
passé premièrement en 2000 en 2009
madame la sénatrice les taux de
prélèvement sur les pannes sont de 10
%. ils augmentent d'un peu plus de 1,5 %
par an pendant 3 ans en
2012 ils sont de 15,5 % ce qui signifie
qu'en 3 ans
la majorité que vous souteniez a prélevé
sur les épargnant français 6 milliards 6
milliards 6 milliards sans aucune
distinction de capacité contributive
c'està-dire surtous les patrimoines
quels qu'ils soi vous parlez madame la
sénatrice avec des mots choisis de Hold
Up quand nous prenons une mesure
d'harmonisation qui consiste à faire en
sorte que tous les produits d'épargne se
voi prélever de façon identique et qui
conduit un prélèvement de 600 millions
mais lorsque vous prélevez en 3 ans 6
milliards sur les épargnants français
c'est une bonne manière qu'on leur fait
vous conviendrez madame la sénatrice que
j'ai quelques difficultés à accéder à ce
type de raisonnement parce que je
comprends que l'on puisse en politique
s'opposer je comprends qu'il soit
parfois nécessaire pour les nécessités
de l'argumentation de convoquer des mots
qui blessent inutilement ou qui
travestissent la réalité mais moi je
considère que ce qui compte c'est la
réalité et la vérité donc la vérité
c'est quoi c'est que vous avez pris une
mesure d'augmentation massive des
prélèvements sociaux sur les produits
d'épar entre 2009 et 2012 plus 6
milliards et que nous avons pris une
mesure qui consiste à faire en sorte que
tous les produits d'épargne par souci de
simplification et d'harmonisation soi
taxé de façon identique et je veux la
donner des précisions qui sont
incontestables vous avez aujourd'hui des
Peel des PEA des produit d'assurance vie
qui sont d'ors et déjà taxés à 15 % à la
sortie et d'autres qui ne l'étaient pas
vous parlez de rétroactivité il n'y a
pas dans cette mesure de rétroactivité
puisque cette mesure est une mesure qui
s'applique après que les contrats ont
été dénoués avant que les contrats
n'aient été dénoués qui ne s'applique
qu'aux contrats qui ont été dénoués
après que la mesure a été annoncée 3ème
point vous parlez de mettre à cage
fiscal moi je ne connais comme ministre
du Budget que les chiffres je viens de
vous donner les chiffres concernant les
décisions qui ont été prises par la
précédente majorité concernant les les
prélèvements sur les produits d'épargne
mais je connais les chiffres des
prélèvements globaux vous les connaissez
vous-même aussi parce que vous avez un
esprit rigoureux 20 milliards en 2011 20
milliards en 2011 12 milliards en 2012
l'actuelle majorité ajoute 8 milliards
en loi de finance rectificative ça fait
21 et 20 en 2013 le budget qui est
présenté devant la représentation
nationale pour 2014 c'est si je
neutralise les de la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale 1 milliard de prélèvement
supplémentaire la séquence annualité
budgétaire après annualité budgétaire
c'est donc 20 milliards de prélèvements
en 2011 21 milliards en 2012 20
milliards en 2013 1 milliard en 2014 et
je prends l'engagement devant vous pour
peu que je dépasse la durée moyenne de
vie d'un ministre du
Budget que les budgets mais je le
souhaite à moi-même aussi parce qu'après
tout je ne peux pas compter sur vous
pour me le souhaiter bien donc 2000
2015 2016 2017 je prends l'engagement
d'un équilibrage des budgets du pays
exclusivement par des économies en
dépense sans recours au prélèvement
obligatoire mais la POE fiscale madame
la sénatrice c'est maintenant parce que
quand on est à 20 mais non mais non mais
madame la sénatrice soyons rigoureux et
soyons précis quand on est à 20 de
prélèvement 20 milliards de prélèvements
en
2011 1 milliard en 2012 20 milliards en
2013 et qu'en 2014 on ne prélève plus
que un et qu par la suite c'est zéro ça
s'appelle comment ça s'appelle une
augmentation du niveau des prélèvements
obligatoires non donc voilà ce que nous
voulons faire et pour ce qui concerne la
mesure dont il est question je regrette
vraiment dans le contexte que connaît le
pays et dont le président s'est exprimé
avec sur lequel le président s'est
exprimé avec des mots choisis comme
souvent il le fait d'ailleurs DS lors
que la République est en question au
cours des dernières heures que l'on
puisse convoquer des concepts des mots
comme hold up escroquerie
gouvernementale comme je l'ai entendu à
l'Assemblée nationale alors que ce que
nous faisons n'est rien d'autre qu'une
mesure de simplification et
d'harmonisation destinée à faire en
sorte qu'on puisse stabiliser le paysage
pour les épargnants je trouve que cela
dans le contexte n'est ni sage ni
conforme à la réalité et ni
responsable mes chers
collègues qure amendements qure
amendements maintenant dans cet article
8 qu' amendement identique de
suppression de l'article le 87 d'abord
présenté par Monsieur Milan oui monsieur
le Président merci je dois dire monsieur
le ministre que j'ai apprécié la douce
sérénité avec laquelle vous avez
présenté votre façon de travailler et
permettez-moi de de justifier notre
amendement de suppression en vous disant
que en revenant sur l'ancienne méthode
de calcul plus avantageuse puisquelle
pointit en compte le taux appliqué lors
de la constitution du capital et en
taxant la totalité des acquis depuis la
souscription auutau actuelle de 155 % ce
nouveau mode de calcul se traduira en
fait et quand même par une hausse de 600
millions d'euros de de prélèvement sur
ces produits d'épargne à long terme et
c'est pour cela que nous présentons cet
amendement de
suppression merci chers collègues
l'amendement
145 il est présenté par Monsieur roche
oui l'objet de cet amendement est bien
sûr de supprimer cet article qui entend
taxer tous les produits de placement
effectués depuis 1997 au taux maximal de
15 et5 %. cet article Nivelle par l'eau
la taxation des placements de type PEA
PEL ou contrat d'assurance vie il
abroche le calcul au taux historique
pour que tous les placements ouverts
depuis 1997 fasse l'objet du prélèvement
social aujourd'hui maximal de 15,5 %.
monsieur le ministre vous venez nous
dire que cette hausse de taxation ne
s'appliquerait contrat qui serait signé
à partir de la publication de la loi
c'est ce que vous VZ nous dire mais ce
qu'on avait lu c'est que ça s'appliqué
de façon rétroactive à partir de
1997 un dispositif par nature
rétroactive donc totalement inéquitable
et qui pose un sérieux problème de
sécurité juridique et de confiance
légitime heureusement après son adoption
par l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement reculé finalement le
périmètre serait réduit au seul contrat
d'assurance vie
multisupport on peut se réjouir bien sûr
de ce de ce retour en arrière j'espère
que il n'est pas fait pour des
considérations diverse et varié mais qu'
est fait parce qu'il y a un problème
d'éthique on peut pas changer la règle
du jeu en cours de partie il y a des
gens qui ont signé qui ont placé leurs
économie dans des PL et des PEA en
sachant la taxation qu'ils auraient
depuis 1997 et aujourd'hui on leur dit
c'est 15,5 % donc je pense que votre
recul est lié à des problèmes d'éthique
mais alors pourquoi le garder pour les
assurances vie m support
car les règles d'éthiques ne se
saucissonnent pas monsieur le
ministre merci chers collègues
l'amendement
167 Monsieur vatrin Madame
Pasquet merci monsieur le Président nous
souhaitons également supprimer cet
article 8 mais vous l'aurez compris pas
tout à fait pour les mêmes raisons que
nos collègues de
l'opposition cet Article 8 tant à
imposer les contrats d'assurance vie à
un taux de prélèvements sociaux de 15,5
% a fait l'objet d'un important travail
de réécriture de la part des députés il
faut dire qu'initialement il prévoyait
d'appliquer un tel taux à d'autres modes
d'épargne particulièrement populairire
c'est-à-dire souscrit par des familles
modestes tels que le plan d'épargne
logement à la suite des travaux des
députés ne sont plus concernés que les
assurance vie sans que nous soyons
certains d'ailleurs que les contrats en
euros c'est-à-dire uniquement investis
en fond euros soit réellement exclus de
ce dispositif pourtant ces contrats sont
ce souscrits essentiellement par les
salariés qui refuse une épargne
spéculative comme cela est le cas
lorsque les contrats sont dit
multisupport c'est-à-dire qu'il comporte
à la fois un fond en euros et des unités
de comptees investis en part de si cave
en action ou en obligation je dois
d'ailleurs dire que je ne comprends pas
la logique qui conduit le gouvernement à
vouloir taxer ses
contrats et ses supports et à écartter
les plan d'épargne en action qui
accueille toutes sortes de titres action
sicave ou au pcvm on voit mal quelle
logique pourrait conduire à ce que ces
supports soient taxés s'ils sont adossés
à une assurance vie et pourquoi ils
devraient ne pas l'être lorsqu'ils sont
adossés à un PEA qui plusé j'en finirai
là sur cet amendement les assurances vie
ne sont nécessairement ne sont pas
nécessairement des contrat qui abritent
des épargnes importantes l'instauration
d'un seuil d'application aurait été
légitime ou tu du moins l'application
d'un taux de préplacement progressif
ou encore proportionnel aux sommes
contenu dans ces contrat qui plusé nous
l'avons dit et nous l'avons proposé à de
multiples reprises il nous semble que
d'autres revenus que ceux dont il est
question ici comme les revenus
financiers des entreprises peuvent être
mobilisés utilement et dans la justice
pour toutes ces raisons il nous semble
plus prudent dans l'état actuel de la
rédaction de cet article d'en proposer
la
suppression l'amendement 297 rectifié
monsieur Barbier
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je crois
qu'on a dit beaucoup de choses sur cette
affaire simplement l'impression qu'on a
c'est l'impression de cacophonie au sein
du gouvernement euh c'est c'est bien le
problème que avec ces allés-artetours
qui qui ont été au moment de l'Assemblée
nationale et en ce qui nous concerne
c'est seulement hier soir que nous avons
eu votre votre nouvel amendement avec
cette nouvelle proposition je crois que
dans cette affaire c'est essentiellement
les ménages qui sont parvenus avec
beaucoup
de difficultés à se constituer une
petite épargne et je crois que sans
viser bien entendu les grands revenus je
crois que on touche là véritablement au
cœur de nos nos concitoyens qui on le
voit bien se rebelle contre cette
pression fiscale un peu dispendieuse
pour tout le monde et qui nous mène
aujourd'hui à ne pas savoir où on va en
matière de fiscalité alors monsieur le
ministre vous avez pris un engagement
formel de dire que l'année
prochaine les prélèvements ne
dépasseraient pas 1 milliard et bien je
crois que une preuve de votre volonté de
de ne pas matraquer fiscalement nos
concitoyens serait de revenir sur cette
d'accepter cette pression de cet article
8 bien mes chers collègues je demande au
rapporteur général la viis de la
Commission sur ces quatre
amendements monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
quatre amendements 87 145 167
297 qui ont été présentés par nos
collègues monsieur Milon roche madame
Pasquet monsieur Barbier propose de
supprimer l'article 8 mettant ENF à
l'application du régime des taux
historiques applicaes à certains
produits de placement l'exlication
donnée tout à l'heure par monsieur le
ministre était particulièrement
convaincante j'ajouterai les éléments
suivants la remise en cause du régime
des taux historiques applicable au
produits de placement exonéré d'impôt
sur le revenu est a priori légitime je
vais expliquer d'une part ce régime
conduit à appliquer sans raison
objective deux régimes socio distinct à
des produits financiers de même nature
et partageant la même profondeur
historique les plusvalues imposables à
l'impôt sur le revenus sont soumises aux
prélèvements sociaux au taux en vigueur
au moment de la réalisation de la
plus-value donc soit 155 aujourd'hui
alors que les produits d'un plan
d'épargne en action ou d'une assurance
vie bénéficient de l'application des
taux historiques de même les produits de
prime versé le 1er janvier 1998 sur un
contrat d'assurance vie en unité de
compte sont soumis au prélèvements
sociaux au taux en vigueur lors de leur
dénouement ou de leur rachat alors qu'un
même montant versé un an plusutôt sur ce
même contrat bénéficie de l'application
des taux historiques d'autre part cette
méthode de calcul entraîne une grande
complexité à chaque nouvelle évolution
des prélèvements sociaux par création ou
augmentation de leur taux notamment pour
le calcul des plus value ou moins value
intercalaire elle se traduit par une
lourdeur de gestion pour les
établissements financiers qui doivent
conserver l'historique des produits
générés pour chaque contrat et
multiplier les lignes dans les
déclarations fiscal et génère des
incompréhensions voire des réclamations
des épargnants auprès de leurs
établissements de leur établissement
gestionnaire compte tenu chers collègues
des inquiétudes exprimées par les
épargnants concernés et leurs
associations et des doutes suscité par
une mesure touchant uniformément des
produits aussi hétérogènes que donc
l'assurance vie l'épargne logement
l'épargne salariale le gouvernement a
toutefois annoncé son intention de
modifier le dispositif initial propose
ainsi un amendement destiné à sortir les
Peel les Ceel et les PEA et l'épargne
salariale du champ de la mesure ce qui
me paraît susceptible d'apaiser les
craintes exprimées par certaines et
certains compte tenu de cette évolution
du dispositif j' mettrai un avis
défavorable aux différents amendements
de suppression de l'article
merci Monsieur le Ministre l'avis du
gouvernement s'il vous plaît
oui l'avis du Gouvernement est est
favorable à la suppression de cet
article et je voudrais en quelques
secondes profiter
de cet avis du gouvernement sur ces
amendements pour apporter deux ou trois
précision d'abord madame la sénatrice
vous proposez un amendement de
suppression sous prétexte que cette
mesure serait une mesure qui pourrait
affecter les petits contrats d'épargne
je juste vous indiquer madame la
sénatrice que je ne comprends pas la
cohérence de la démarche qui vous
inspire puisqu'il y a de cela quelques
minutes vous venez de présenter un
amendement augmentant de 5 % les
prélevements sociaux sur tous les
produits du capital et tous les produits
d'épargne qui aurait eu un effet
beaucoup plus abrasif que la mesure
d'harmonisation que nous présentons et
et qui est complètement contradictoire
du discours que vous venez de tenir
l'augmentation de 5 % des prélèvements
sociaux sur l'ensemble des produits
d'épargne constituerait un prélèvement
massif sur les petits contrat d'éparne
dont bénéficient les Français les plus
modestes c'est la raison d'ailleurs pour
laquelle je vous avais incité tout à
l'heure à retirer cet amendement et vous
proposez maintenant que l'on supprime
cet amendement sur l'assurance vie qui
est totalement contradictoire de ce que
vous avez indiqué à l'occasion du même
débat il y a quelques minutes sur un
sujet absolument semblable donc je vous
demande madame la sénatrice par souci de
cohérence de retirer cet amendement qui
encore une fois est orthogonal de celui
que vous avez présenté il y a quelques
minutes pour le reste
pour les sénateurs et sénatrices de
l'opposition je veux je veux encore une
fois bien repréciser les choses pour que
malgré les clivages qui peuvent exister
entre les groupes de la majorité de
l'opposition qui sont bien légitimes on
puisse quand même sur ce débat avoir une
approche qui soit entre nous la plus
apaisée la plus rigoureuse et la plus
honnête possible il ne s'agit pas d'une
taxe ni d'un prélèvement supplémentaire
sur l'épargne
des produits d'épargne semblabl et je
vais prendre un exemple très concret un
produit d'assurance vie sur lequel des
versements sont intervenus
antérieurement à 97 et postérieurement à
97 pour les versements qui sont
intervenu antérieurement à 97 au moment
de la sortie du contrat l'épargnant se
verra appliquer la reconstitution des
taux historiques par année et pour les
versements qui sont postérieurs à 90 7
il se verra appliquer le taux de sortie
actuel des prélèvements sociaux
c'est-à-dire qu' 5 % sur le même produit
au point que un certain nombre de
professionnels eux-mêmes nous indiquent
que les épargnants qui bénéficient pour
un même contrat d'assurance de
dispositifs de sortie aussi complexe ont
du mal eux-mêmes à
reconstituer le calcul du taux de
prélèvement qui s'applique à eux prier
point deuxème point donc c'est une
mesure de simplification d'harmonisation
de
stabilisation je veux rappeler que en
2006 un de mes anté anenté anté ané
prédécesseur qui s'appelait
Jean-François Copé a pris des mesures
concernant les prélèvements sur les
produits d'épargne qui ont conduit des
Françaises et des Français à qui étaient
en franchise d'impôt à l'entrée d'un
certain nombre de produits à se trouver
massivement fiscalisé de façon
rétroactive à la sortie le Conseil
constitutionnel a eu se prononcer a eu à
se prononcer sur cette décision prise à
l'époque par un de mes prédécesseurs qui
a une responsabilité éminente comme
leader de l'opposition actuellement le
Conseil constitutionnel n'a rien à y
retrouver n'a rien trouvé à y redir en
droit et à l'époque ceux qui le
soutenaient n'ont rien trouvé à y redire
en principe politique enfin dernier
point nous faisons une réforme de
l'assurance vie je le dis pour madame la
sénatrice debr extrêmement précise dans
son contenu elle n'est pas pas aléatoire
n'est pas flou ça a été présenté ce
matin au Conseil des ministres et devant
la commission des finances de
l'Assemblée nationale il s'agit d'un
dispositif qui incite ceux qui ont placé
leurs fonds en assurance vie à
s'orienter vers des placements à risque
plutôt queà des placements garantis pour
le faire dans des conditions fiscales
qui soient avantageuses nous mettons en
place pour les fonds eurocroissance un
dispositif dit de fourgoussage qui
permettront aux épargnants de garder le
bénéfice de l'antériorité de leur
placement sur les fond fonction sur les
placements en eurogarantie et pour ceux
qui passent de l'eurog garantie à
l'eurotransmission il garderont la
totalité de leurs avantages fiscaux dès
lors que au-dessus d'un million d'euros
ils passeront de l'euro garanti vers les
produits à risque c'est une réforme qui
a fait l'objet d'une concertation
approfondie j'ai reçu ce matin les
associations des parnons pour leur
présenter cette réforme qu'ils ont reçu
très positivement et si nous retenons
dans notre mesure qui fait l'objet de
votre amendement l'assurance vie et pas
les autres produits c'est précisément
parce que nous sommes dans cette
approche globale d'une réforme de
l'assurance vie qui qui repose sur trois
principes très simple la simplification
d'où cette mesure d'harmonisation la
stabilisation du paysage de l'épargne
d'où cette réforme globale de
l'assurance vie qui s'inscrit dans la
durée et troisièmement l'orientation des
fonds de l'assurance vie vers le
logement et vers le financement de
l'entreprise au moment où les
entreprises ont besoin de fonds propres
et où nous avons besoin de les orienter
vers la croiss
merci si j'ai bien compris monsieur le
ministre l'avis est défavorable c'est
bien ce que j'ai compris merci donc avis
défavorable du gouvernement avis
défavorable de la commission explication
de vote mes chers collègues madame
procacia monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre si je vous ai bien
j'ai bien compris monsieur le le
ministre et monsieur le rapporteur vous
nous prés prenter cette mesure comme une
mesure de simplification et
d'harmonisation pour le gouvernement et
pour les établissement bancairire ou
assuranciel pour les épargnants
effectivement je ne vois pas l'avantage
d'autant plus que quand même depuis y
compris les réformes que vous avez cité
de et vous avez cité le précédent
ministre Jean-François Copé on na jamais
remis en cause la date de 97
c'est-à-dire que vous créez une
instabilité alors que ça fait depuis
plus de enfin moins de 16 ans mais ça
fait 16 ans que des contrats ont été
souscrits vous nous parlez maintenant de
cette nouvelle réforme et je crois avoir
lu madame cararine berger dire qu'elle
souhaitait que ce ne soit pas une mesure
prise dans le projet de loi de
financeces
ou ou un projet de loi de finance
rectificative mais qu'elle voulait une
réforme globale donc même ceux auxquels
vous avez confié un rapport vous ne
suivez pas ce qu'ils ont recommandé dans
dans le rapport elle voudrait une
réforme globale et là vous êtes en train
de proposer une nouvelle réforme de
l'assurance vie au même moment où vous
remettez en cause des avantages acquis
depuis des années et un système qui nous
semblait être un peu près le seul qui
n'avait pas été bouleversé par les
différentes lois fiscales votées sous un
gouvernement de droit ou sous un
gouvernement de gauche bien à mon avis
monsieur le ministre vous êtes par cette
mesure en train de plomber votre futur
réforme merci chers collègues monsieur
Savari
oui c'est tout à fait ça monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre Oui pour
confirmer que véritablement je crois que
les Français en ont assez des
prélèvements et vous avez fait une
analyse sur quelques années qui montrait
que vous partagiez ce constat de dire
que les prélèvements avaient été trop
importants vous avez citer un chiffre de
milliards prélevé monsieur le ministre
par la majorité précédente et vous
prenez cela comme exemple et si le
diagnostic peut-être établi le
traitement nous ne le partageons pas et
vous avez amené maintenant votre part
significative à ces Hauses de cotisation
je vous rappelle que dans la loi
retraite hausse de cotisation retraite
de 6 milliards et demi vous voyez un
partout la hausse de la fiscalité sur
certains produits de placement que l'on
discute aujourd'hui ça ne concerne
paraîtt-il que 600 millions d'euros mais
nouvelle cotisation dé plafonné pour le
régime des indépendants l'article 9
qu'on va voir élargissement de
l'assiette en ce qui concerne les
cotisations agricoles et on sait que nos
agriculteurs n'en peuvent plus j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion d'intervenir ils
commencent à en avoir ralbol et je crois
que c'est pas as signe positif qu'on
leur donne en élargissant encore ses
cotisations sociales quand on connaît
les retraites dont il disposent après de
nombreuses années de labeur la baisse du
coocient familial hein 1 milliard
d'euros pour 1,3 million de ménage la
fiscalisation des contrats collectifs en
ce qui concerne les complémentaires
santé on voit bien qu'on est loin de la
posuse fiscale annoncé je crois que
véritablement vous vous engagez
maintenant dans une deuxème partie du
quinquena à faire à lever le pied par
rapport à à ces augmentations mais il
sera trop tard donc nous vous rejoignons
dans cette volonté de poste fiscale et
nous vous proposons à travers la
suppression de l'article 8 de joindre
les actes à la parole et nous allons
même plus loin ce qui est tout à fait
essentiel nous sommes là pour faire des
propositions constructif pas forcément
pour critiquer mais je crois que il est
important de donner des signes de
montrer un cap car les Français sont
déboussolés on le voit tous les jours
malheureusement à travers des des
événements qui sont bien sûr tout à fait
difficilement acceptables dans une
société dans un contexte
particulièrement difficile donc voilà ce
qui nous caractérise qui nous
différencie monsieur le ministre vous
faites des promesses vous tenez des
paroles nous nous faisons aujourd'hui
des actes forts en suppréant ces
prélèvements
supplémentaires merci Monsieur longuer
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
j'interviens parce que en répondant à
madame Isabelle Debray monsieur le
ministre vous avez voulu donner des
leçons qui ne sont pas justifiées de
votre part ou plus précisément de la
part de votre
gouvernement le besoin de pause fiscale
ser ralbol ce n'est pas l'opposition
qu'il a exprimé avec force en premier
c'est votre patron monsieur moscovissi
ministre de l'économie et des finan à
même et il a rencontré dans le pays un
écho largement supérieur au moyen de
diffusion et de polémique que
l'opposition et que l'UMP en particulier
peuvent mettre en œuvre il y a un appel
du ministre à une pause fiscale et il y
a une réponse de l'opinion à un besoin
de pause fiscale nous sommes les témoins
d'une situation conflictuelle que vous
avez que votre Ministre a dénoncé que
vos actions ont explique et que
l'opinion tranche par un refus de votre
politique je ne reviendrai pas sur les
mesures que vous avez que vous proposer
dans le budget 2014 nous l'examinerons
mais nous aurons l'occasion de démontrer
que c'est bien plus qu'un milliard que
vous demandez plus de demander en plus
au ménage mais nous n'allons pas faire
le budget général maintenant nous le
ferons le moment venu vous avez évoqué
en effet la
fiscalisation ou plus exactement
l'assiette des contrats d'épargne de
long terme au bénéfice de la sociale
nous l'avons lancé en 2010 vous avez
tout à fait raison de le dire mais nous
l'avons fait dans une politique
d'ensemble vous n'aviez pas le temps
dans votre réponse à Madame Debray de
rappeler tout ce que nous avons fait
pour améliorer la productivité de
l'économie française pour alléger les
dépenses publiques pour engager des
mesures structurelles qui expliquent
qu'en effet nous avons à cet instant et
dans ce contexte particulier mobiliser
les produits d'épargne au service d'une
politique de redressement elle été jugée
par les élections présidentielles et les
élections législatives je n'y reviendrai
pas mais il serait intellectuellement
honnête lorsque vous évoquez un chiffre
de le replacer dans ce contexte global
et non pas de le sortir de cet effort de
productivité et de redressement des
finances publiques que nous avions
engagé dernière observation et pour moi
ce sera la plus importante ce
gouvernement est décourageant parce
qu'il ne nous donne aucune raison des
espérer dans le succès de la France vous
n'allégez pas la dépense publique
contrairement à ce que vous annoncez
vous n'améliorez pas la productivité et
vous prenez à parti les entreprises pour
la raison qu'elle ne se battraiit que
sur le terrain de la compétitivité par
les coûts alors qu'il faudrait selon
vous et vous avez raison épuiser le en
tous les cas approfondir le terrain de
la compétitivité par la qualité par la
valeur ajoutée simplement pour la valeur
ajoutée il faut de l'épargne or
contrairement à ce que l'on croit notre
pays est insuffisamment producteur
d'épargne certes la France a des
statistiques en apparence séduisante
c'est comme not démographie en apparence
notre démographie est bonne en réalité
nous n'avons pas si l'on écarte le
vieillissement le renouvellement des
générations et en matière d'épargne si
l'on on écarte le financement de l'État
et le financement du logement il n'y a
pas de financement suffisant pour la
modernisation des entreprises grandes ou
peties pour les plus grandes c'est moins
grave elles sont globales et elles se
finanent sur le marché global pour les
entreprises moyennes et pour les petites
entreprises c'est un véritable défi
comment voulez-vous susciter une
confiance dans l'épargne avec une mesure
qui est ressentie comme rétroactive
certes elle n'est pas rétroactive au
sens du Conseil constitutionnel puisque
seuls les contrats dénoués après seront
frappés mais vous reconstiuez en quelque
sorte une fiscalité qui n'a pas lieu
d'être une fiscalité favorable pour
laquelle les épargnants s'étaient
engagés vous n'empêcherez pas monsieur
le ministre les Français de considérer
que les raisons pour lesquelles ils ont
épargné à long terme leur sont assez
largement retiré et c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous portez un mauvais coup au
besoin de financement des entreprises un
mauvais coup à la modernisation des
entreprises et c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette mesure directement
inspiré par les bureaux de Bery et Dieu
sait si le SLF est riche et fertile dans
son imagination et qu'ils vous ont
proposer suggérer comme ils l'ont
proposé d'ailleurs je vous rassure à
tous vos prédécesseurs la différence
c'est que vous vous l'avez accepté et en
choisissant le court terme vous
compromettez le redressement nécessaire
de notre économie française
monsieur le minist je vous propose de
répondre à l'issue des explications de
vote on va il y a encore deux
explications de vote pour le moment et
vous répondra ensuite monsieur
Cardou monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre cher collègu j'ai écouté
attentivement la réponse de Monsieur le
Ministre à Isabelle Debré et c'est vrai
que c'est pas facile monsieur le
ministre de vouloir justifier ce qui
n'est pas justifiable et depuis un
certain temps on a l'impression que ce
gouvernement pardonnez-moi d'utiliser
une métaphore un peu facile euh est
devenu un danseur de tango on fait un
pas en avant deux pas en arrière on crée
une taxe on mesure les réactions de la
population à cette taxe on y revient on
donne des compensations et on ne sait
plus par quel bout prendre le
contribuable français alors pour ce qui
concerne ce dossier cette taxation des
produits de placement euh vous nous avez
proposé en dernière minute un am
amendement qui retirait de la base
d'imposition certains produits de
placement tournés vers l'épargne
économique comme l'épargne salarial ou
les PEA en y laissant en y laissant les
produits d'assurance vie adossés à des à
des unités de compte à des supports
économiques ou à des multisupports qui
sont en fait un drainage de l'épargne
vers l'économie réelle du pays donc si
j'ai bien compris le mécanique du
gouvernement on maintient cette cette
imposition là et j'ai bien écouté aussi
votre explication en disant ce n'est pas
une nouvelle taxe c'est la modulation
d'un taux d'une ancienne taxe mais
précisément comment on peut-on concevoir
que des épargnants qui ont eu confiance
à un certain moment au produits que leur
proposaient les organismes financier en
cours de exécution de leur plan
d'assurance
se voit retaxer alors qu'il ne l'avait
pas prévu donc là il y a un problème
d'équité vis-à-vis des épargnants en
fonction de la date à laquelle ils ont
effectué leur versement et à la date à
laquelle ils vont dénouer leur contrat
d'assurance vie et précisément je
reviens au cœur du problème j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire hier soir dans la
discussion générale pour que on
rétablisse une certaine confiance dans
ce pays il faut un certain nombre de
facteurs des ingrédients que Ch chacun
devrait avoir à l'esprit et en
particulier j'en cite deux la lisibilité
et la stabilité et là avec ce que vous
êtes en train de faire vous détruisez
totalement ces deux notions de
lisibilité et stabilité et j'en viens à
ma conclusion c'est une interrogation
nous avons vu les uns et les autres que
ce matin je crois en conseil des
ministres était présenté de nouveaux
produits d'épargne tournés vers
l'économie dont on verra quelle
peut-être l'efficac cité puisque si j'ai
bien compris les les incitations
fiscales étaient relativement mesurées
quant à ces nouveaux produits d'épargne
mais comment
voulez-vous alors que ça paraît bien
naturel d'essayer de débloquer des
sommes relativement dormante et peu
rémunéré sur les les les les comptes
livra qu'on les retourne pour qu'ell
puisse financer l'économie réelle de ce
pays comment voulez-vous que les
épargnants à qui vous allez proposer ces
produits d'épargne nouvel mode suivant
ce que vous
aurez ce que vous aurez réalisé et bien
que ces épargnants ils
souscrivent ils vont dire d'un côté on
on on surtaxe les contrats euh tournés
vers l'économie en maintenant un taux à
15 % sur les contrats en unité de compte
donc qui financeéconomie d'un autre côté
c'est bien cette politique du tango on
crée un autre produit
pour récupérer l'épargne euh vers les
contrats productifs en matière
économique comment voulez-vous que ces
épargnants et confiance dans la parole
d'un gouvernement qui juste avant de
mettre en œuvre ce nouveau dispositif
vient de montrer qu'à tout moment il
pouvait revenir en arrière sur les
engagements qui avaient été pris pour
fixer l'épingle d'une manière durable
donc comprennent qui pourra comme l'a
dit Isabelle Debray elle vous avait posé
cette question bon c'est vrai qu'elle
pouvait pas vous pouviez pas répondre à
tout mais j'insiste à nouveau on est en
train de constater que vous faites tout
et son contraire
merci chers collègues Monsieur Philippe
B merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues je voudrais
à mon tour exprimer les raisons de mon
opposition à cette article qui institue
sous couvert d'une réorganisation des
prélèvements sur un certain nombre de
produits d'épargne un prélèvement
supplémentaire monsieur le ministre car
enfin nous voulons bien croire à vos
motivations d'ordre esthétique puisque
vous nous parlez d'harmonisation et de
simplification il reste tout de même que
le ministre du budget que vous êtes n'a
pas manqué d'être intéressé par la
ressource de 600 millions d'euros qui
est apporté par cette disposition et
vous ne nous ferez pas croire que ça n'a
pas été votre motivation principale nous
nous fondons sur les travaux qui sont
conduit dans notre assemblée pour
apprécier votre mesure et pour ma part
j'ai pris connaissance très
attentivement de l'excellent
rapport de nos rapporteurs et notamment
monsieur Yve
dodini bien sûr que le régime actuel
d'imposition de ces placements se révèle
hétéroclite et monsieur deini n'a pas
manqué de le
relever en disant ce régime
hétéroclite minor pour les produits de
placement concernés le montant des
prélèvements sociaux à quité par
l'épargnant c'est dit élégamment mais
c'est très clair et pour qui n'aurait
pas
compris parce que le travail que nous
faisons dans cette assemblée est un
travail honnête et exact monsieur dodini
nous explique en termes financiers et
tout à l'heure notre collègue Alain
Milon parmi d'autres le rappelit la
mesure proposée conduira d'après les
données déclaratives relative à 2012 un
gain total de 600 millions d'euros en
2014 qui se répartira en 450 millions
d'euros pour les organisme affectataire
de la sécurité sociale et 150 millions
d'euros pour les fonds gérés par l'État
alors de grâce ne jouons pas sur les
mots il s'agit bien d'un nouveau
prélèvement alors le petit jeu qui
consiste à remonter à la Préhistoire
pour savoir qui a créé le plus d'impôts
en France est parfaitement vain car
l'exigence d'une pause fiscale compte
tenu de la saturation des contribuables
français c'est ici et maintenant qu'elle
s'exprime et je crois qu'il est grand
temps de considérer que c'est le
gouvernement en place qui a la
responsabilité de prendre les mesures
nécessaires je dois ajouter s'agissant
de ce projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui vient une semaine
après le rejet par le Sénat de la
soi-disant réforme des
retraites comporte de nombreuses
dispositions en
recette beaucoup d'autres lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale l'ont
fait aussi il est vain de le nier alors
pour l'assurance vieillesse les
collègues ont rappelé à juste titre
l'augmentation des cotisations
d'assurance vieillesse mais on peut
aussi parler euh de l'augmentation des
taux applicables au au prélèvements sur
les contrats complémentaires qui ne
seraient pas des contrats responsables
les prélèvements supplémentaires sur
l'industrie du médicament les
prélèvements supplémentaires
pour les artisans et les commerçants ils
existent déjà en 2013 il y en a eu pour
près d'un de plus d'un milliard 100
millions d'euros et l'année prochaine
nous en avons de nouveau au moment même
d'ailleurs où la TVA à quitté par les
artisans va augmenter de 5 à 7 de 5 5 à
7 %. alors oui il y a des prélèvements
supplémentaires et en dehors de ces
prélèvements supplémentaires il faut
aussi parler de toutes ces mesures qui
sans prendre d'impôt sur
supplémentairire vont réduire le pouvoir
d'achat je pense à la mesure qui est une
mesure sournoise de recul de la date de
l'indexion des pension de retraite je
pense à la disposition qui vraiment est
une disposition célérate consistant à
demander au retraités de payer pour la
dépendance et de donner l'argent pour
financer le fond de solidarité
vieillesse la deuxième année de suite
alors vous dites aux gens payez pour la
dépendance et puis vous utilisez
l'argent pour autre chose ça n'est pas
convenable je le dis vraiment
sincèrement et au chapitre des
augmentations d'impôts
fiscalisation d'une partie de plutôt
plafonnement de l'avantage du ccient
familial qui est resserré et puis aussi
enfin fiscalisation des avantages
familiaux de retraite on peut pas dire
que ce ce texte soit un texte qui
n'augmente pas systématiquement et tous
asimute les prélèvements et on ne peut
pas dire cette mesure qu'il s'agit ici
de supprimer ne soit pas une mesure de
rendement pour améliorer les
recettes merci chers collègues madame
Pasquet
oui merci monsieur le
Président j'ai monsieur le ministre vous
m'avez interpellé donc évidemment j'ai
ça ça m'a quelque peu troublé mais en
même temps en vérifiant je ne suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous je je
tenais à répondre parce que je ne
voulais pas euh vous laisser dire que
vous laissez sous-entendre que le groupe
CRC fait à la fois une chose et son
contraire dans les au travers de ces
amendements en tout cas moi je ne suis
pas devenue une grande spécialiste de
placement financier de façon soudaine
mais en tout cas ce que je peux vous
dire ce que nous avons compris de de de
ces articles et des les raisons pour
lesquelles nous avons déposé ces
amendements cet article propose 8
propose de taxer les contrats
d'assurance vie alors que l'amendement
précédent que nous avions déposé euh il
s'agissait des revenus de placement
alors les assurances vie peuvent être en
en obligation mais par contre toutes les
obligations ne sont pas
euh euh des assurances vie voilà alors
peut-être que effectivement nos
amendements ont été rédigés de façon
maladroite en tout cas euh les arguments
que j'ai exposé concernant l'amendement
de suppression de l'article 8 tiennent
toujours euh et en l'occurrence euh
celui
euh de de de qu'il aurait été préférable
dans le cadre de de la taxation des
assurances vie de de mettre un plafond
ou un seuil enfin tout dépend où dans
quel côté on se place de façon à faire
la distinction entre les foyers modestes
qui choisissent ce mode de placement et
les foyers plus riches et qui ont les
moyens de faire dé placements plus
importants merci Monsieur de cessa
oui monsieur le Président merci nous
envisageons avec al archimau de voter
comme le gouvernement et le groupe
socialiste j'avais simplement euh une
question à Monsieur le Ministre s'il
pouvait nous préciser la notion de
rétroactivité exactement mais en
quelques mots monsieur le ministre mais
c'est pour bien comprendre et être sûr
de se vote en faveur du
gouvernement je propose madame
Debray madame Debray explication de
vote il n'y a pas d'autrre demande
d'explication de vote monsieur oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
essayer de m'exprimer avec une douce
sérénité je vais essayer je vais essayer
parce
que monsieur le ministre vous m'avez
répondu effectivement vous aussi avec
une douce sérénité je vais essayer de
faire la même chose nous n'avons pas
tout à fait la même sémantique hier
c'est vrai que quelqu'un vous avait
employé le mot de holdup alors vous je
crois que vous
aviez vous aviez parlé de reroutage
voilà voyez c'est pour vous dire qu' je
suis quand même les débas tout à l'heure
je vous ai dit qu'on manquait de clarté
vous m'avez dit que j'avais parlé de
flou je n'ai jamais employé ce terme
ensuite je vous ai parlé de de problème
effectivement de de taxation
supplémentaire vous m'avez dit que
j'avais parlé de rétroactivité vous
regarderez mes propos je n'ai pas parlé
de rétroactivité donc je crois monsieur
le ministre que quand vous me répondez
je je vous écoute avec beaucoup
d'attention mais il faudrait vraiment me
répondre sur ce que je vous ai dit et
non pas sur ce que je ne vous ai pas dit
je voudrais aussi dire autre chose vous
me dites qu'il n'y a pas de de de de
prélèvement supplémentaires d'impôt
supplémentaires 600 millions d'euros de
prélèvement supplémentaires alors moi je
vais vous dire je ne vais pas parler de
façon comment dire technocratique mais
de façon pratique et j'exprime un
sentiment que les Français expriment
aujourd'hui dans les médias dans la rue
un peu partout stop au prélèvement
fiscaux je vais pas vous redire le mot
de holdup puisque ça ne vous plaît pas
de reroutage comme vous le voulez mais
mais aujourd'hui il y a une overdose
fiscale vous nous dites que vous allez
faire une pause fiscale donacte mais ça
fait quand même plusieurs mois que vous
nous le dites et toutes les semaines il
y a un impôt supplémentaire un
prélèvement supplémentaire alors en
sémantique je vais être très CLA
monsieur le ministre les Français
attendent vous parlez d'harmonisation de
de de
simplification les français eux
n'attendent pas ça les Français
attendent
stabilité clarté et
visibilité
merci je laisse la parole à Monsieur le
Ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur et je
voudrais répondre à quelques à
quelquesuns des sujets qui ont été
évoqués par les différents orateurs en
essayant de répondre à la fois à ce qui
est dit et parfois aussi madame la
sénatrice à ce qui est sous-entendu et
parfois ce qui est sous-entendu peut
être plus puissant que ce qui est dit et
vous AZ évoquer essentiellement quatre
sujets à travers les différentes
interventions d'abord les prélèvements
et la dépense publique est-ce que nous
tenons ou pas la dépenses publiques la
question de la fiscalité de l'épargne le
financement des entreprises et les
prélèvements obligatoires bon je vais
répondre très brièvement à ces quatre
points d'abord monsieur le sénateur
longuer pour ce qui concerne les
prélèvements obligatoires nous avons une
trajectoire devant l'Union européenne
qui permet à l'Union européenne et elle
ne manque pas de le dire de mesurer très
exactement ce que nous faisons en terme
de prélèvement obligatoire nous sommes
engagé au titre du programme de
stabilité dans une trajectoire qui
aurait dû nous conduire en 2014 à
augmenter le niveau des prélèvements
obligatoires de 03 % là où il avait
augmenté au cours des dernières années
2011 2012 2013 d'un peu plus de 0,5 %.
la réalité de l'évolution des
prélèvements obligatoires pour 2014 si
je neutralise leseffet de la fraude
fiscale et c'est reconnu à la fois par
le Haut Conseil des finances publiques
et par l'Union européenne donc nous
sommes départagés vous et moi c'est 0,3
et si je neutralise l'effet de la lutte
contre la FRE fiscale 0,15 voilà la
réalité c'est pardon c'est 0,15 et si je
neutral 015 et si je neutralise l'ffit
de la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
pardon 005 c'està-dire 1 milliard je
parle des prélèvements obligatoires et
ce que je dis est extrêmement précis
c'est dans les rapports du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques et c'est
absolument
incontestable deuxème point vous parlez
de la dépense publique mais monsieur
longé vous avez été membre d'un
gouvernement qui pendant 5 ans c'est
également dans le rapport des comptes de
la Cour des comptes de juillet 2012
c'est dans le rapport des Ha Du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques a
augmenté la dépense publique de 170
milliards d'euros je vais vous donner
deux autres chiffres pour vous
convaincre l'évolution de la dépense
publique entre 2002 et 2007 a été de 2,3
% l'augmentation de la dépenses
publiques entre 2007 et 2012 de 1,7 %
dans le projet de budget qui vous a
présenté l'évolution de la dépense
publique c'est 0,4 ce qui veut dire
qu'en 18 mois nous avons divisé par 5
l'augmentation de la dépense publique je
vais vous prendre un autre chiffre la
révision général des politiques
publiques à laquelle vous avez
abondamment participé déclaration de
Monsieur Fillon de 2010 la révision
générale des politiques publique c'est
l'alpha et l'oméga de la bonne gestion
des finances publiques puisque nous
allons entre 2010 et 2013 dégager 10
milliards d'euros d'économie nette le
budget qui vous est présenté cette année
cette année pour 2014 c'est 15 milliards
c'estàdire qu'en un an je fais 5
milliards de plus que vous n proposiez
d'en faire en 3 ans 9 milliards sur
l'état qui absorb le tendanciel
d'ugmentation c'est tout à fait juste 9
milliards 9 milliards mais je vais vous
donner le détail monsieur longu puisque
vous m'interpellez 9 mais pas du tout
non monsieur le sénateur je je vous ai
écouté sans vous interrompre et je vous
réponds je vous réponds tout simplement
et avec beaucoup de précision nous
faisons 15 milliards d'économie en 2014
9 milliards sur l'état 6 milliards sur
la protection sociale le tendentiel
augmentation de l'État et de 7,5
milliards nous faisons 9 milliards ce
qui permet de dégager 1,5 milliards de
diminution des dépenses sur l'état les 9
milliards sur l'état se décomposent de
la manière suivante 3 milliards sur
l'état et ses administrations central
200 milillards 7 sur les opérateurs de
l'État dont les dépenses de
fonctionnement ont augmenté de 15 %
lorsque vous étiez en situation de
responsabilité